Wenn ihr diesen Song schon mal gehört habt, dann wisst ihr das danach. Traditionellerweise das Chaos Radio beginnt hier auf Fritz. Der Blue Moon ist für drei Stunden in Beschlacht genommen vom Chaos Computer Club. Ich sag das ja gerne wie bei DJs, die Residenz heute hier im Haus sind der Harald und der Frank. Meine Person Max Formalotki passt natürlich wie immer einfach nur auf. Und dann haben wir noch einen Gast, nämlich den Jörg. Herzlich willkommen. Hallöchen. IT-Berater, der sich mit dem Thema auskennt, mit dem wir uns heute Abend beschäftigen. Wir haben ja schon mal kurze Andeutung erfahren bei Paul, der sich gerade verabschiedet hat, dass es sich um so was wie den ganz großen Lauschangriff dreht. Es werden bestimmte Verordnungen, Verordnete, die in der Schwebe sind, die Jungs werden das gleich noch ausführen, dass jetzt eben so was wie E-Mail und Co. auch abgehört werden darf und soll. Und das soll heute Abend das Thema sein, weil es bietet reichlich Angriffspunkte, sowohl für User als auch für solche, die jetzt in Zukunft sich bereitstellenderweise mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen.
Wir wollen euch gerne erklären, wie das funktioniert, wie das technisch funktioniert, was die gesetzlichen Grundlagen dafür sind und vor allem auch, ob es Sinn macht, seine Mails zu verschlüsseln oder nicht. Und wollen mit euch darüber reden, was ihr über so riesige Abhörmaßnahmen denkt, wie ihr euch dabei fühlt, wenn eure E-Mails mitgelesen werden von den Behörden. Wie privat sind eure E-Mails eigentlich? Macht euch das vielleicht alles gar nichts aus? Und Chaosradio ruft an und wir beantworten eure Fragen und reden mit euch.
Genau. Und bevor wir uns die ganze Arbeit machen, also so richtig mit Werbe ins Thema schmeißen, fragen wir euch doch direkt mal, ob euch das überhaupt was ausmacht. Weil wenn ihr jetzt alle sagt, ach komm, also meine E-Mails kann gerne jeder lesen und mich da auch abhören in allen Maßen, dann können wir uns die Sendung auch sparen und ganz viel Musik spielen. Das heißt, so ein bisschen Empörung unter 0317097110 wäre jetzt vielleicht nicht falsch. Wir sammeln uns hier, stecken uns ans Internet und sind dann gleich für euch da. Ihr hört das Chaos Radio auf Fritz und ich dachte mir schon, dass ihr uns auf die Probe stellen wollt, ob wir jetzt wirklich nur Musik spielen. Wir wissen, dass das Thema natürlich etwas Erklärung verlangt, bevor ihr euch vielleicht selber da reinarbeiten könnt und euch hier meldet, um euren Senf dazu zu geben. Deswegen, wie wir es immer machen beim Chaos Radio, in den ersten Minuten erstmal eine Einführung in das, was da so spannend ist. Das Problem ist immer beim Chaos Radio, dass die meisten Sachen zwar super spannend sind, aber weil sie eben noch kein anderer entdeckt hat, total kompliziert, weil noch keiner was richtig ausformuliert hat, noch nicht mal die, die das Ganze jetzt an den Start bringen, nämlich die Bundesregierung.
Wir versuchen, denke ich mal, zum Anfang mal so ein paar Begriffe zu erklären, weil diese ganze Materie ist eigentlich sehr trocken, obwohl E-Mails und sowas könnt ihr euch was darunter vorstellen. Ihr wisst wahrscheinlich auch, was ein Service Provider ist, was ein E-Mail-Anbieter ist. Es könnte sowas sein wie gmx.de oder Hotmail. Es kann aber auch sowas sein wie T-Online, wo ihr vielleicht euren DSL-Anschluss habt. Das ist also so ein Mischding, weil die beides anbieten. Die bieten also Postfächer an, die bieten einen Internetzugang an. Die Telekom ist ein Telefonanbieter und bietet damit Zugangsleitungen an fürs Telefon. Das heißt, da könnt ihr euch über ISDN oder über Modem einwählen. Das sind also sogenannte Verpflichtete, über die wir heute Abend reden. Das heißt also, das sind welche, die gesetzlich verpflichtet sind, irgendwelche Abhörschnittstellen zur Verfügung zu stellen. Das heißt also, das sind solche Firmen in der Regel oder Institutionen, die also für die Öffentlichkeit Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen anbieten. So nennt sich das. Das heißt also, die bieten euch an, hier könnt ihr euch registrieren, kostenlos und kriegt ihr einen E-Mail-Account. Wobei das dann teilweise schon wieder in fragliche Bereiche geht. Das heißt, wann ist jemand davon betroffen, wann nicht, welche Größenordnung muss es annehmen. Es ist auf jeden Fall jemand, der euch einen DSL-Anschluss anbietet, der dann zwar nicht von der E-Mail-Überwachung direkt betroffen ist, sondern von der normalen Leitungsüberwachung. Da wird dann wieder unterschieden. Das sind also alles diese Bereiche verpflichtet, über die wir heute Abend reden.
Also um nochmal den einfachen Schritt zu gehen, bis dato haben wir ja gehabt Telefonüberwachung, also wenn irgendwie Gangster A mit Gangster B telefoniert hat, dann hat man da im Zweifelsfall, wenn man den Gerichtsbeschluss hatte, mal abgehört und möglicherweise irgendwelche tollen Gespräche mitgeschnitten. Das Ganze geht jetzt nicht nur noch auf Telefon, sondern das geht eben halt auch auf allen anderen Wegen der elektronischen Kommunikation. Da will man zumindest hin.
Genau. Und wenn wir jetzt schon von den Gangstern reden, die da abgehört werden, da gibt es also drei wichtige Begriffe, die wir heute Abend versuchen werden zu trennen, wo aber schon auch die Begrifflichkeiten in den Gesetzen sagen, oder der Sprachgebrauch, der da genommen wird, ist, wie schwierig das teilweise ist. Es gibt nämlich die Beschuldigten, es gibt Betroffene und es gibt Beteiligte. Also Beteiligte und Betroffene in etwa gleich sind. Interessant, also beschuldigt heißt in den Gesetzen meist ist der Betroffene. Also da wird auch teilweise so eine absichtliche Begriffsverwischung gemacht, um einfach ein bisschen zu verbergen, das ist jetzt meine Behauptung, um zu verbergen, wie viele Leute eigentlich wirklich von so einer Maßnahme betroffen sind. Das heißt also, wenn mein Anschluss jetzt abgehört wird, was gegen mich zum Beispiel ermittelt wird, und ich schreibe jetzt dem Max eine E-Mail, dann ist er ja auch betroffen, weil seine E-Mail ja auch mitgelesen wird im Prinzip. Der ist ja sozusagen auch betroffener von einer Maßnahme, obwohl ich eigentlich nur Beschuldigter bin. Und da gibt es also vom Max-Planck-Institut, gibt es ja Zahlen, dass man sagt, dass bei einer Maßnahme, das heißt also bei einer Überwachungsanordnung, werden also von einem Beschuldigten im Schnitt 50 bis zu 50 Betroffene, sind dann mit betroffen oder 50 Beteiligte sind dann bei so einer Überwachungsmaßnahme.
Das heißt, wenn du der Gangster bist, dass 50 Kumpels von dir, egal ob die nun auch böse sind oder nicht, automatisch damit in das Raster fallen?
Richtig. Und schließlich ist es ja irgendwie ein ganz erheblicher Eingriff, ein Grundrecht, was ich auch habe, nämlich, dass es ja also gibt ein Fernmeldegeheimnis und es gibt also ein Recht, dass meine Kommunikation, dass die Kommunikation, die wir beiden haben, sei es per E-Mail oder per Telefon, dass die also erstmal grundsätzlich geschützt ist. Und es gibt also gesetzliche Einschränkungen, die es möglich machen, dass eben trotzdem Polizei, Geheimdienste, Behörden, Ermittlungsbehörden auf diese Kommunikation zugreifen dürfen. Auch auf die Umstände der Kommunikation. Das heißt also nicht auf die Inhalte selbst, sondern auf die Tatsache, dass wir kommunizieren, wann wir und von welchem Server aus wir kommunizieren. Das sind also dann die Begleitumstände.
Aber im Grunde wissen wir das doch schon lange, dass E-Mails nichts anderes sind. Also wenn wir jetzt mal von dem populären Beispiel ausgehen, als Postkarten, die man sowieso lesen kann, wenn man möchte. Also verlässt man sich da doch eigentlich ohnehin nicht drauf. Ist doch egal.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich dieser Ansatz. Ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen. Ich schreibe nichts Wichtiges in E-Mails. Das wollen wir auch von euch wissen. Wie ist das eigentlich? Habt ihr euch da schon mal Gedanken drüber gemacht? Wie wichtig sind eigentlich die E-Mails? Wie findet ihr das, wenn ihr mit eurer Freundin, möglicherweise auch sehr intime Dinge hin und her mailt? Wie fühlt ihr euch dabei? Sind das eigentlich wirklich öffentliche Sachen? Behandelt ihr die E-Mails wie Postkarten? Oder glaubt ihr eigentlich, dass es vertraulich ist? Oder welche Ansprüche habt ihr an das Medium? Und würdet ihr, wenn ihr das jetzt wisst, dass das breitwarend nicht stattfindet, diese Abhörmaßnahmen, würdet ihr möglicherweise auch Verschlüsselung einsetzen?
Das wäre mal die Frage an euch. Ich reiche die einfach mal durch. Unter 03.3.1.70.97.110 könnt ihr euch natürlich am Chaosradio beteiligen. Wie fühlt ihr euch jetzt angesichts der Tatsache, dass das ab diesem Jahr wirklich so ist, ab diesem Jahr darf das abgehört werden? Es ist also nicht mehr in der Schwebe oder so oder es kommt vielleicht, sondern es ist ziemlich sicher und es wird bald viele, viele Leute betreffen. Deswegen wollen wir eure Meinung dazu hören. Verschlüsselt ihr vielleicht schon oder ist euch das im Endeffekt egal? Und ihr sagt, was ich in meine E-Mails schreibe, mein Gott, interessiert sowieso keinen. Und wenn ich da lese, herzchen ich küsse dich, ich mag dich, ich liebkurse dich an intimen Stellen, dann liest der Typ das halt und freut sich auf der anderen Seite. Aber das ist mir ja egal. 031 77 97 110 ist die Nummer.
Richtig. Und richtig, wir haben auch noch eine E-Mail Adresse. Und zwar, sobald wir hier Internet haben, können wir die auch lesen.
Wir haben Internet.
Wir haben Internet, wunderbar. Dann schreibt bitte an 99, also 99, at chaosradio. ccc.de. Da könnt ihr Fragen direkt zur Sendung loswerden. Oder wenn ihr allgemeine Sachen zu Chaos Radio habt, irgendwelche Themen, Vorschläge oder andere Fragen, dann schreibt ihr an chaosradio. ccc.de. Und was haben wir denn sonst noch heute Abend anzubieten? Chat, Forum?
Wir können natürlich auch im Forum einen kleinen Thread aufmachen. Das heißt, wenn ihr lieber lesen wollt, was auch andere Leute zu dem Thema schreiben und eine kleine Diskussion soll aufkommen. Vielleicht macht der Harald ja gleich mal einen Thread auf. Da müsst ihr sich natürlich anmelden, dass er extrem umständlich ist. Oder www.fritz.de. Nein, das geht ganz einfach. Wenn ihr da mitmachen möchtet, haben wir unter interaktiv unsere Foren. Da werde ich in der Multimedia-Ecke einfach mal einen kleinen Thread anlegen, wenn ich eine Atempause habe. Und da könnt ihr dann auch eure Meinung posten. Oder einer von euch macht es einfach in Berlin und Brandenburg. Bitte, da muss ich es nicht machen. Schönen Thread. Thema Chaosradio heute Abend. Abhörmaßnahmen beziehungsweise der große Lauschangriff. Das könnte doch mal einer in Angriff nehmen, ich guck dann gleich mal rein.
Vielleicht eine kurze organisatorische Ansage noch. Wir haben wieder verstärkt das Augenmerk auch auf die Streams gelegt. Das heißt, diese Sendung wird sowohl als MP3 in drei Qualitätsstufen als auch als Org-Word bis in mehreren Qualitätsstufen angeboten. Ihr könnt einfach auf chaosradio.ccc.de gehen. Da sind dann Links auf die Streams.
Vielleicht solltet ihr auch noch anmerken, dass es auch wieder bei Wikipedia bei der deutschen Wikipedia eine Mitmachseite gibt. Da könnt ihr also einfach direkt per Wiki, wenn ihr damit vertraut seid, Fragen, Links, zusätzliche Links reinpacken. Die werden wir jetzt während der Sendung auch bearbeiten. Da haben wir auch ein bisschen angefangen, die Vorbereitung für die Sendung drin zu machen. Dazu geht ihr auf de.wikipedia.org, also die deutsche Wikipedia-Seite. Und sucht da am besten einfach nach Chaosradio. Und geht dann da auf die Seite, da ist ein Link für die Sendung 99, da gibt es die Vorbereitungsseite dafür.
So, jetzt seid ihr dermaßen versorgt, dass ihr für die nächste halbe Stunde sowieso nichts mehr aufnehmen könnt. Deswegen lassen wir jetzt einfach mal den Lutz sprechen, der ist nämlich am Telefon. Na, Abend, Lutz.
Na, Band.
Du hast angerufen.
Und zwar, ja gut, ich verschlüsseln meine E-Mails, wenn es geht, wenn ich irgendwie mal einen Partner finde, der das auch benutzt. Schon seit geraumer Zeit mit PGP. Aber ich habe da auch schon einige abenteuerliche Erlebnisse gehabt. Unter anderem zum Beispiel, dass mein Steuerberater, das ist ein relativ sensibles Thema, vierteljährliche Auswertungen völlig unverschlüsselt übers Netz geschickt hat und auch überhaupt nicht verstanden hat, dass ich ihm versuchte beizupolen, dass man solche sensiblen Daten nicht einfach so verschicken kann. Also das Bewusstsein ist leider überhaupt nicht gegeben bei dem Thema.
Es gab auch schon Fälle, wo irgendwelche Kreditkartendaten und Passwörter auch unverschlüsselt gesendet wurden. Und was benutzt du denn da? PGP oder du benutzt da PGP?
Ich hab das auch versucht, bei zig Freunden einzurichten. Die haben sich das interessiert angeguckt und haben dann aber abgewogen. Dann haben sie gesagt, viel zu kompliziert. Immer so eine Pass-Phrase und was weiß ich nicht. Und eben dieser berühmte Satz, das, was ich verschicke, das interessiert eh keinen. Es ist also bis hin zum Steuerberater ein schreckendes Nichtbewusstsein, was das angeht.
Man muss ja dann auch mal grundsätzlich unterscheiden, zwischen wer hört da mit? Sicherlich sind irgendwelche Kommunikationen mit Anwälten, Steuerberatern dergleichen, sensible Daten. Dann gibt es aber sicherlich noch eine Reihe von Leuten, die auf dem Standpunkt stehen und sagen, ja klar, ich möchte nicht, dass das Hinz und Kunst mitlässt, denn jeder Support-Mitarbeiter bei dem ASP, wo ich bin, sondern berechtigte Stellen eben. Also irgendwelche Fahndungsbehörden, die die Aufgabe haben, irgendwie hier Straftaten zu verfolgen oder irgendwie für Sicherheit zu sorgen. Das ja noch mal irgendwie zu differenzieren zwischen den beiden Kategorien. Zumindest für viele Leute.
Ja gut, aber ich finde es erschreckend, wenn jetzt jemand, der einfach nur persönliche E-Mails verschickt, dass der vielleicht dieses Bewusstsein nicht unbedingt hat. Das kann man ja zum Teil noch nachvollziehen. Aber das geht ja eben bis hin zu wirklich so sensiblen Daten. Ja, jetzt bis hin zu dieser elektronischen Umdachsteuer-Voranmeldung, die vorgeschrieben ist, wo es überhaupt kein Authentifizierungsverfahren gibt.
Ja, das ist sicherlich die älteste Thematik, ist sicherlich noch mal ein ganz interessantes Thema wie vieles andere, aber heute nicht das Thema des Chaosradios. Die werden ja auch nicht per E-Mail verschickt, diese ältester Steuererklärungen.
Aber wer in das System reinkommt, kann sie auch lesen. Und jeder kann mit Datenunfug treiben da.
Ja, nicht dass zu trotz, sicherlich ein Problem, mit dem man sich befassen kann, aber hat jetzt mit der überwachung von, also mit der staatlich legitimierten Überwachung von E-Mail basierter Kommunikation und von Internetzugängen eigentlich nichts so im direkt zu tun.
Gut, das stimmt eigentlich, ja.
Gut, dann nehmen wir erstmal deine Meinung so mit, Lutz. Danke für den Anruf. Danke, tschüss. Der Erik ist dran, am Telefon, aus Dresden. Hallo, Erik.
Hallo. Ja, hallo.
Tachchen, wie ist deine Meinung zu dem Thema?
Ja, also ich finde natürlich, dass es absolut irgendwie beschissen ist. Und das aber irgendwie dann doch, also Entschuldigung, wenn ich das hier so sage, aber ich glaube, dass irgendwie dadurch dieser Staat doch dann irgendwie selber sein Gesicht zeigt. Also, ich persönlich, wenn ich E-Mails verschicke, ich schicke ja keine sensiblen Daten so, ich schicke ja nur an irgendwelche Freunde oder so. Und wenn ich jetzt irgendwie ein Moab planen würde, würde ich das ja nicht bei E-Mails verschicken, aber das schenke ich auch nicht aus. Also, bei mir macht das ja nichts aus. Aber trotzdem finde ich, dass es irgendwie eigentlich irgendwie nicht sein kann. Und ich wollte nur mal fragen, wie man das jetzt begründet hat. Weil das ja eigentlich verfassungswidrig ist, oder? Weil das besteht ja eben doch gegen Grundrecht.
Ja, nicht wirklich. Weil es ist ja so, in Artikel 10 Grundgesetz steht drin. Fernmeldegeheimnis und Postgeheimnis sind uns verletzlich, es sei denn, es gibt eine Ausnahme durch ein Gesetz. Die Ausnahme ist halt hier die, dass im Sinne der Strafverfolgung, was wir alle sagen würden, okay, Verbrecher, Leute, die mit Drogen handeln und so, wissen die Götter, sollen auch irgendwo verfolgt werden. Da gibt es halt Ausnahmen, da können in ganz bestimmten Fällen und auch nicht einfach so nach Lust und Laune, sondern auf Anordnung eines Richters Telefongespräche und jetzt halt auch neuerdings E-Mail, Internetzugang, abgehört werden. Und das ist halt die Begründung, dass man sagt, okay, es gibt hier ein überwiegendes öffentliches Interesse. Das öffentliche Interesse ist die Strafverfolgung und die auch stark begrenzt ist auf einem Katalog von Straftaten.
Die sogenannten Katalogstraftaten?
Die sogenannten Katalogstraftaten, richtig. Und deswegen ist es hier gerechtfertigt, dass man so eine Ausnahme machen kann von dem Artikel 10. Der ansonsten auch hochgehalten wird und deswegen ja auch der Richter vorbehalte. Ich darf also nicht als Polizist hingehen und abhören, sondern ich brauch den Beschluss seines Richters dazu.
Genau, wobei es also nicht nur eingesetzt, sondern es ist eine ganze Reihe von Gesetzen, die das Grundgesetz an der Stelle einschränken. Und was sind die wichtigsten davon?
Also die wichtigsten sind einmal die Strafprozessordnung, also genau dann 100A und 100B Strafprozessordnung. Dann gibt es das sogenannte G10-Gesetz. Das heißt G10, weil es halt nach Grundgesetz Artikel 10. Das bezieht sich halt auf die Fragen ja sogenannter strategischer Aufklärung, also bundesnachrichtendienst, militärischer Abschiedendienst, solche Sachen, die sind da geregelt. Und dann gibt es noch das Außenwirtschaftsgesetz oder wie es neuerdings heißt, das Zolldienstfahndungsgesetz. Das heißt, da geht es um Fragen der Zollfahndung, Kriegswaffenkontrollgesetz, Waffenschmuggel, solche Geschichten, die sind da geregelt. Wobei man sagen muss, dass der 100A, B, StPO mit dem Richtervorbehalt noch die niedrigste Hürde hat. Wenn ich eine G10-Anordnung haben will als Verfassungsschutz, da gibt es auch einen eigenen Prozess für. Der füllt irgendwie zwei DIN A3-Blätter. Also das ist ein riesiger Papierkrieg, bis ich überhaupt so ein Erlaubnis des Innenministers in dem Fall kriege, sowas durchzuführen.
Ja, aber es klingt auf dem Papier alles schön. Da muss ein Richter beschließen und das nur in begründeten Fällen und auf Antrag und so weiter. Gab es nicht erst irgendwie von, ich weiß nicht, welcher Stelle, eine Rüge, dass Telefonanordnungen zu ungeprüft und zu schnell durchgewunken werden von Richtern?
Naja, also was man natürlich sagen muss, wir haben, und das ist der Kritikpunkt daran, wir haben eine Inflation dieser Anordnung. Also wenn man sich eine Kurve malt, wie viele Anordnungen gibt es über die Jahre hinweg, hat das irgendwann mal vor, ich hab die genauen Zahlen jetzt nicht im Kopf, aber vor fünf, sechs Jahren hat das irgendwann mal was unter 10.000, jetzt sind wir mittlerweile schon nach 130.000 erkannte, was die Zahl der Anordnungen pro Jahr angeht. Und das legt den Schluss nahe, dass einige Richter oder das Richter teilweise zu schnell auf dieses Mittel zurückgreifen und zu schnell Anordnungen zu unterschreiben. Aber das ist wie gesagt auch immer eine Frage des Einzelfalls. Aber die nackten Zahlen sprechen halt dafür, dass es wesentlich häufiger vorkommt als noch vor Jahren.
Aber liegt das nicht vielleicht auch einfach daran, dass es, wenn man es jetzt positiv sehen will, einfach mehr in diesem Bereich passiert ist, was man überwachen kann auch, dadurch, dass es einfach mehr gebraucht wird? Oder auf der anderen Seite, dass es jetzt so einfach geworden ist, dass man es halt schneller mal machen kann?
Na ja, es ist natürlich in den letzten zehn Jahren eins dazugekommen, dass die Verbreitung des Mobilfonds, Handys. Und das ist natürlich eine Geschichte, die inflationäre Telefonanschlüsse einfach vermehrt hat. Muss ja auch sagen, es gibt ja auch einfach viel, viel mehr Anschlüsse. Festnetzanschlüsse, DSL-Anschlüsse, was weiß ich, Handys und so weiter. Und dadurch wird es halt einfach provozional auch mehr. Also das kann man auch sagen. Aber da hat sich eigentlich auch noch nie richtig jemand drum gekümmert, inwieweit das zusammenhängt. Also da kenne ich niemanden, der da mal eine Untersuchung drüber geschrieben hat, ob es einfach irgendwie eine Korrelation zwischen den beiden Zahlen gibt. Es ist natürlich auch sehr einfach geworden durch die technischen Möglichkeiten.
Also ich weiß, es gab einen Spiegelartikel mal, wo sich, ich muss lügen, ich glaube es war das Bundeskriminalamt, hatte sich mal darüber beschwert, dass jetzt heutzutage die Täter haben. Wie war das? Wir haben irgendwie vier Täter, die jeweils acht Mobilfunkkarten haben und mit 32 Freunden ihre Telefone tauschen. Und das würde jetzt die plötzlich sprunghaft gestiegenen Zahlen der Telefonüberwachungsmaßnahmen erklären, weil dadurch einfach die Fallzahlen so hoch werden.
Ja, na das ist halt, das ist tatsächlich, was man auch vielleicht an der Stelle noch mal sagen muss, weil das am Anfang ein bisschen unklar rübergekommen ist. Also auch in der Vergangenheit wurden E-Mails schon abgehört, vereinzelt, ja. Also das ist passiert, da gibt es auch offizielle Zahlen dazu, die vielleicht mit Vorsicht zu genießen sind, aber es gab das auch schon in der Vergangenheit. Was jetzt neu ist seit 1.1. dieses Jahres, ist, dass Provider oder allgemein Anbieter von solchen Telekommunikationsdiensten Schnittstellen bereithalten müssen. Standardisierte Schnittstellen für den Fall, dass jemand abhören möchte, damit diese Abhörung sofort und unverzüglich umgesetzt werden kann. Und natürlich kann man jetzt argumentieren, dadurch, dass man jetzt solche Möglichkeiten vorhält, so technische Einrichtungen überall installiert, ist das nicht sozusagen, man macht das Abhören leicht und dadurch erhöht man die Zahl der Abhörungen. Weil es so leicht ist abzuhören.
Erik, sag mal, schützt du dich dann auch dagegen? Oder sagst du, ja gut, dann befinde ich mich halt damit ab und schreib nur noch den Unsinn über Mail und den Rest mach ich Face to Face?
Ja, wahrscheinlich erletzt.
Ich glaube, ich besitze so eine zu geringe EDV-Kenntnis, um da irgendwas zu verschlüsseln. Also ich hab irgendwie, ja, also irgendwie, also ich hab keine Ahnung so richtig, wie das gehen soll.
Da kannst du mal nach GnuPG suchen, also GPG oder PGP. Das ist auch für Privatanwender kostenlos. Und das ist eigentlich so das verbreiteste. Ich denke, wir werden da später in der Sendung noch was zu sagen. Also wir haben auch hier eine Mail bekommen, zum Beispiel vom Alexander, der uns gefragt hat, ob man uns auch hier verschlüsselte Mail schicken kann. Nee, das geht nicht. Wir haben ja vom Chaosradio gerade keinen öffentlichen Schlüssel. Haben wir jetzt keine Lust, eine Mail zu schreiben, beantworte ich mal so. Da war auch noch eine Frage vom Friedrich dazu, auch wie das funktioniert mit diesem Schlüsselaustausch und sowas zu PGP. Ich denke, wir werden einfach mal noch eine praktische halbe Stunde einlegen.
Okay.
Eric, vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Jo, wir waren ja gerade schon bei der technischen Seite. Und was da jetzt alles so an Pflichten auf die Provider oder eben halt Diensteanbieter zukommt, ist das irgendwie schwierig jetzt zu realisieren? Ist das was Besonderes? Weil wenn ich mich jetzt nicht damit auskenne, was mein Provider so zu leisten hat, ist das jetzt eine groß angelegte Aktion? Oder ist das schnell gemacht, was da gefordert ist?
Na das kommt darauf an, also einerseits muss ein bestimmter Übergabepunkt vorgehalten werden, das heißt es muss einen Anschluss geschaffen werden an ein Netz, das Direkttp betreibt.
Direkttp ist die Regulierungsbehörde für Post und Telekommunikation?
Dann muss ich natürlich in irgendeiner Form, kommt es dann drauf an, was ich für ein Mail-Server habe. Das heißt, es ist einfach den anzuschließen, oder es ist schwierig, da hängt da Aufwand von ab. Was aber dann noch dazukommt, ist der ganze organisatorische Aufwand, der damit verbunden ist, dass ich halt verfügbar sein muss. Also wenn ich, gerade wenn es größere Anbieter sind, über 10.000 Teilnehmer, muss ich halt rund um die Uhr, 365 Tage im Jahr, auch außerhalb der Geschäftszeiten, solche Anordnungen, wie es dann heißt, also wenn jemand sagt, ich möchte jemanden abhören, unverzüglich umsetzen können. Also auch wenn das mitten in der Nacht per Fax kommt, muss jemand da sein, der das entgegennimmt und umsetzt. Und auch unter 10.000 ist es so, dass ich in verdrehtbaren Zeiträumen, also maximal sechs Stunden, das umgesetzt haben muss. Und das ist einfach auch eine organisatorische Auflage. Die Technik ist in vielen Fällen trivial, aber diese ganze organisatorische Apparat darum und vor allen Dingen dann die Absicherung der Technik, die Protokollierung der Maßnahmen, die Behandlung von Fehlern, die ganze Kommunikation zwischen den anordneten Stellen im Falle von Fehlern und solchen Sachen, das ist auch teilweise immer ein sehr großer personeller Aufwand.
Das heißt, ich kann quasi jemanden abstellen, der da 24-7 sitzt und quasi diese Anforderungen im Zweifelsfall stellen kann, aber in der Regel wahrscheinlich gar nichts zu tun hat, weil es relativ selten vorkommt.
Naja, wenn du ein richtig großer Anbieter bist, dann wird es vielleicht schon häufiger vorkommen. Jörg, du hattest vorhin eine Zahl genannt, mit was die Regulierungsbehörde rechnet.
Also es gibt ja, es gibt so einen Erfahrungswert aus dem Mobilfunk und man rechnet irgendwo maximal mit Anordnungen pro Jahr im Bereich eines Promils.
Das heißt?
Na das klingt erstmal sehr wenig, aber es ist eine in 1000. Und wenn man sich vorstellt, man hat 24 Millionen Mobilfunk-Teilnehmer, dann sind es 24.000 Anordnungen, wenn ich jetzt richtig gerechnet habe. Und das wär schon eine Menge, das wär fast eine Verdopplung. Ansonsten gibt es in der technischen Richtlinie eine Formel, die muss man hier nicht wiederholen. Wie groß die Anlage sein muss, die ich vorhalten muss. Also wie viel gleichzeitige Maßnahmen muss die Anlage unterstützen? Und da gibt es eine Formel, die praktisch nach der Anzahl der Teilnehmer berechnet, wieviel diese Anlage verkraften muss. Aber das würde ich jetzt hier zu weit finden.
Was auch interessant ist, ist, dass es ja unterschiedliche berechtigte Stellen gibt, die so eine Abhörmaßnahme beauftragen können auf unterschiedlicher Rechtsgrundlage. Und zum Beispiel ein Teilnehmer muss von mehreren dieser Stellen gleichzeitig überwacht werden können und die Stellen dürfen auch untereinander nicht merken, dass jetzt gerade jemand anderes auch noch überwacht. Also ich muss nicht nur einmal eine Kopie oder sowas dann im Zweifelsfall anfertigen, sondern eben bis zu drei oder so an unterschiedliche Stellen.
Der BND und der Zoll und die dürfen nicht voneinander wissen.
Sie merken, wenn höchstens der Datenfluss langsam wird, dann wissen sie jetzt, die Leitung ist dicht.
Oder zwei verschiedene Landeskriminalämter.
Aber so in Sack und Tüten ist das alles noch nicht, dass die jetzt ganz genau wissen, welche Pflichten ich da nun wirklich habe, was die Bereitstellung anbelangt. Also das Pflegen dieser Leitung, die die dann benutzen und so weiter, die machen doch auch noch was. Oder muss ich denen das alles irgendwie auf dem silbernen Tablett savieren, wenn ich kurz sage, ja?
Das ist auch Sinn dieses Standards, dass das halt wirklich alles mundgerecht aufbereitet wird. Und das ist auch sehr komfortabel. Das ist ein XML-Format, das ist auch definiert, das findet man auch im Internet. Und damit das halt entsprechend automatisiert verarbeitet werden kann, auch auf der Gegenseite.
Und du musstest zu einem Überfluss, musstest du ja auch noch von der Regulierungsbehörde dann abnehmen lassen, das heißt bestätigen lassen, dass dein System funktioniert und darfst du dafür dann auch noch bezahlen für diese Abnahme?
Gibt es schon Schätzungen, was das für ein Kostenaufwand ist, so ein Wirtschaftlicher jetzt mal so in Gesamtdeutschland?
Gesamtdeutschland nicht. Also da ist es noch ein bisschen schwierig. Es gibt so, das ist natürlich eine Sache, über die Provider nicht gerne reden und auch nicht gerne Zahlen rausgeben.
Weil es dann sofort laut wird, dass das dann an den Kunden weitergeleitet wird?
Ja, das ist ja ein unangenehmes Thema eigentlich. Aber es gibt so Schätzungen, um mal eine Bandbreite zu sagen. Also man kann das sicherlich billig realisieren für so um die 25.000 Euro. Das ist denke ich so die Untergrenze, wenn man es ganz allein macht. Aber es gibt mittlerweile auch schon Systeme, die sich mehrere kleinere Provider sharen. Da ist es dann nicht mehr so viel Aufwand, auch von Organisation her, weil halt mehrere Provider zum Beispiel einen Übergabepunkt nutzen. Aber man kann natürlich auch sehr große Systeme, also je nachdem wie viel Teilnehmer man hat, da kommt man auch schnell mal eine viertel halbe Million Euro.
Aber nur mal so ein Beispiel. Ich spiele ja auch zwischendurch im Internet mit meinen Clan-Fuzzis und dann haben wir so einen Server, den wir benutzen für irgendwie 7 Euro im Monat. Es ist ein Voice-over-IP-Programm im Grunde. Das heißt, wir reden mit so kleinen Headsetts übers Internet, über Teamspeak in dem Fall oder Ventrilo oder Skype oder so. Da gibt es tausend Sachen, die die ganz, ganz viele Leute auch benutzen. Und muss dieser Anbieter von diesem Server, der sich auf Gamer spezialisiert hat, das heißt, der wird irgendwie insgesamt vielleicht 300 Kunden haben, das sind irgendwelche Freaks, die selber zocken, muss der das dann auch bereitstellen oder wird dann quasi diese Anforderung wieder an dessen Großprovider weitergereicht?
Das sind jetzt so... Ich glaube, da machen wir mal im nächsten...
Da machen wir mal im nächsten. Da muss ich dir jetzt noch eine Pause für gönnen. Ja, wir machen jetzt erst mal kurz Nachrichten, weil wir haben es halb und danach geht es gleich weiter. Ihr könnt euch natürlich gerne hier einreihen und anrufen. 031 77 97 110 im Chaosradio heute Abend. Der sehr große Lauschangriff. Und wenn der Gerald Lech da ist, dann legen wir sofort los. Dann haben wir nämlich auch denjenigen, der hier die Nachrichten liest.
Wenn Fritz rundum hält sich, dann 91, 9.
Wir haben es 22.30 Uhr.
Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter selbstverständlich. In der Nacht gibt es Schneeregen. Es kann Blattweiden seid ein bisschen vorsichtig. Die Temperaturen sinken auf zwei bis minus ein Grad. Morgen fällt dann zunehmend Regen bei Höchstwerten zwischen sechs und acht Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Goethe-Heinrich.
Verteidigungsminister Struck hat das Urteil des Bundesverwaltungsgerichts zur Werbpflicht begrüßt. Die Richter in Leipzig hatten entschieden, dass die Einberufungspraxis rechtens ist. Ein 22-jähriger Student hatte sich ungerecht behandelt, gefühlt. Bundeskanzler Schröder hat das Einstein Jahr 2005 eröffnet. An der Feier im Deutschen Historischen Museum in Berlin nahmen 800 Gäste teil. Schröder würdigte den Physiker als einen vorbildlichen Wissenschaftler. Einstein hatte vor 100 Jahren die Relativitätstheorie erfunden. In Indonesien hat sich die Zahl der Flutopfer stark erhöht. Die Regierung sprach von 50.000 Toten mehr. Damit kamen in Indonesien mindestens 166.000 Menschen ums Leben. Grund für den Anstieg sind Opferzahlen aus Gebieten, die bisher nicht zugänglich waren. Israel und Palästinenser haben am Abend ihre Sicherheitsgespräche wieder aufgenommen. Vorher hatte das israelische Kabinett dafür gestimmt. Laut Medienberichten will es der Palästinenser-Führung eine letzte Chance geben, die Angriffe auf Israel zu stoppen. Der Verkehr offert keine aktuellen Meldungen zurzeit. Gute Fahrt für euch.
Mein Papa kann nämlich alles.
In Hollywood nannte man ihn The Continental Lover.
Und deshalb kommen Sonntag auch wieder echt coole Gäste. Disco Brutal, zum Beispiel, die kenn ich jetzt nicht, aber dafür gibt's ja schließlich die Show. Und Rainer Krönert, der Typ, der uns derzeit mit Angela-Märkel-Perücke überall in die Hauptstadt anlächelt. Wie gesagt, mein Papi ist schon der echt ausgeschlafene Typ.
Ja, das ist schon ein Spross von dem alten Stamm, der Junge. Ken FM, die Fritz-Radioshow mit Ken Jepsen.
Jeden Sonntag von 14 bis 18 Uhr.
Live in den Fritz Studios in Potsdam-Wabelsberg und im Radio.
Auf Fritz natürlich. Wir haben es kurz nach halb elf. Das heißt, wir haben noch zweieinhalb Stunden Zeit. Im heutigen Fall von Blue Moon handelt es sich um das Chaos Radio. Das heißt, der Chaos Computer Club ist zu Gast Harald Frank, unser noch mal zu Gast Gast quasi, der Jörg IT-Berater seines Zeichens und mein Name Malotky. Großer Lauschangriff heute Abend, das Thema nehme ich seit 2005. Habt nicht nur ihr euch vielleicht fürs neue Jahr was vorgenommen, sondern auch die Behörden in Deutschland. Es soll nicht nur noch Telefone abgehört werden, sondern auch der ganze elektronische Infoverkehr, also Kommunikation derart wie E-Mail und mehr. Was haltet ihr davon? 0-3-77-97-1-1-0. Fühlt ihr euch da extrem in euren Rechten gestört oder sagt ihr, ach E-Mail, das kann man gerne lesen. Das bezieht sich natürlich auch noch auf andere Punkte, wie wir vorhin schon mal kurz erfahren haben, was es da noch für Ansätze gibt und vor allen Dingen, was für Firmen da wichtig ist. Am Telefon ist erst mal die Ina aus Berlin. Ich glaube, die Ina hat sich zurückgezogen. Zwar dezent, aber doch deutlich.
Das hat sie gemerkt, dass sie überwacht wird.
Wahrscheinlich. Von uns. Akustisch. Was sagst du dazu dem Thema? Ist dir das egal oder findest du es sogar begrüßenswert, dass Terroristen und ähnliche Feinde des Staates jetzt auch auf diese Art und Weise überwacht werden können?
Drogendealer, Schlepper, Terroristen, Schwerkriminelle, Bankräuber, böse Menschen.
Also ich bin da eigentlich prinzipiell dagegen. Nach der Frage läuft das dann so wie beim Telefonabhören mit richterlichen Befluss und so weiter.
Im Idealfall schon.
Das Problem ist nämlich einfach nur, man kann es natürlich zur Terrorismus oder kriminellen Bekämpfung einsetzen. Dagegen kann man ja am ersten Moment auch nicht dagegen sagen. Aber das Problem ist, dass man damit dem Staat oder wem auch immer jetzt eben diese Macht gibt, eben Leute zu überwachen auf diese Weise. Und das kann sich dann später auch ausweiten. Also solange das bei der Kriminalität bleibt oder so, würde ich mich da jetzt nie gestört fühlen in meinen Rechten.
Das Problem ist aber, dass das halt ausgeweitet werden kann.
Bei der Interesse halber bist du in der DDR aufgewachsen oder? Bist du in der DDR aufgewachsen? Also ich hörte jetzt so, da klingen halt so im Unterton, höre ich persönlich da so Begriff Stasi raus.
Ja, nee, daran habe ich jetzt weniger gedacht.
Ich bin auch nie so alt, dass ich das miterlebt hätte, richtig.
Aber du siehst es schon als Bedrohung oder als Problem, dass der Staat möglicherweise dann...
Ja, ich denke, es ist prinzipiell schlecht, wenn einem Staat so viel Macht gegeben wird. Die Kommunikation zwischen den Bürgern, also die Unüberwachte, die ist ein wichtiges Grundrecht, denke ich mal. Und es ist ja auch schon beim Telefonabhören oft genug vorgekommen, dass irgendwelche politischen Aktivisten da abgehört wurden. Und wenn das beim E-Mail jetzt genauso weitergeht, dann kann ich das nie wirklich gut halten.
Es ist ja auch so, dass diese Katalogstraftaten, die Liste, die wird ja regelmäßig erweitert. Also da gibt es dann die Möglichkeit irgendwie, der Staat schafft sich die Möglichkeit, diese Abhörungen irgendwann anzuordnen. Und dann alle paar Jahre kommt wieder irgendwie ein Beschluss, ja, jetzt diese und jene Straftat, die kommt jetzt auch noch damit rein, weil den wird auch noch mit abgehört.
Und wenn alles nichts hilft, dann hilft das, dass es eine kriminelle Vereinigung ist und es damit wieder eine Katalogstraft hat.
Ja, das wird sich da noch nicht mehr richtig überblicken.
Was jetzt auch wirklich kritisch ist aus meiner Sicht, ist, dass wir kriegen Anfang des Jahres noch mal eine neue Überwachungsverordnung. Also die jetzige Gültige wird abgelöst und da wird auch ausdrücklich auf Landesrecht erweitert, wobei da nicht drin steht, welches Landesrecht. Und da ist es jetzt so, dass jedes... Also meine Erkenntnis ist, dass es war seinerzeit so ein Kompromiss, weil die Länder hatten damit gedroht, wir machen jeder unsere eigene Überwachungsverordnung, wenn er uns das nicht da reinschreiben lässt. Und deswegen kam das da rein. Und jetzt haben wir halt praktisch nicht nur das eine, die eine TKWV und die eine technische Richtlinie, sondern wir haben auch noch Polizeigesetze von... Wie viele Länder haben wir? 13?
Da stehen so nette Dinge drin, wie zum Beispiel jetzt neuerdings in Hessen beschlossen, dass also auch präventiv, das heißt also zur Gefahrenabwehr, auch Abwehrmaßnahmen gemacht werden können.
Wir haben in Niedersachsen zum Beispiel auch einen Entwurf gehabt, wo es sowas wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung durch die Hintertür gibt, einen Fast-Free sozusagen. Das heißt, ich darf Daten nicht mehr löschen ab Anordnung, muss sie dann speichern, so lange bis jemand sagt, ist gut.
Bis klar ist, ob ich überhaupt zugreifen darf sozusagen.
Stand da zumindest, ist drin.
Thomas, danke dir für den Anruf.
Ich hätte noch eine Frage.
Wie können die eigentlich an die E-Mail-Adressen von den Leuten rankommen? Es gibt ja jetzt auch E-Mail-Anbieter, wo man keinen Namen oder keine Adresse angeben muss. Oder man gibt eben einfach einen falschen Namen an.
Wie können die da richtig an die richtigen Adressen rankommen?
Zur Bewachung.
Tja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Das ist eine spannende Frage. Also da ist es natürlich so, wenn eine E-Mail-Adresse irgendwo auftaucht, in einem kriminellen Zusammenhang. Und ich kann die zurückverfolgen zu einem Provider, dann kann ich aufgrund eines anderen Paragrafen mir von dem Provider die Adressdaten des Kunden geben lassen und kann darauf schon mal eine Anordnung aufbauen. Wenn der Nutzer natürlich einen anonymen E-Mailer benutzt oder sowas, das heißt irgendwo die Spur im Leeren verläuft, habe ich da natürlich verloren. Also da kriege ich dann die Daten auch nicht raus. Und das ist einfach, also in dem Moment, wo jemand diese E-Mail-Adresse gefunden hat, dann hat er auch die Daten, also die Adresse, er muss ja sowieso die Anordnung auf eine Person ausstellen lassen. Das heißt, die Frage stellt sich dann schon gar nicht mehr.
Vielleicht sollten wir auch noch mal irgendwie kurz dieses ganze System umreißen oder den Ablauf, wie das überhaupt passiert. Also wir reden jetzt davon, dass Überwachung gemacht wird und so weiter. Wie läuft das eigentlich konkret ab? Mal ganz kurz in wenigen Sätzen. Ist also so, dass jetzt an dem Beispiel E-Mail, da werden spezielle Rechner installiert bei den Anbietern dieser Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen. Und die entsprechenden Behörden schicken dann eine richterliche Anordnung, sofern sie die erteilt bekommen haben, an den Provider. Da steht dann irgendwie der Name einer natürlichen Person oder so drauf. Und der Provider muss dann eben sozusagen gucken, welcher E-Mail-Account oder welche E-Mail-Accounts gehören zu dieser Person. Und dann werden Kopien der E-Mails und auch der Ereignisse, die mit den E-Mails verbunden sind, wie zum Beispiel von einem Folder in den anderen verschoben und E-Mail gelöscht auf dem Server, was auch immer. Solche Dinge, die werden dann kopiert und über diese Maschine, die dort steht, übertragen an die berechtigten Stellen. Das ist also, um das Ganze mal zu umreißen, dass wir wissen, wovon da gesprochen wird und wie das abläuft, der Reihe nach.
Noch eine Frage, Thomas? Nun hatten wir vorhin schon mal darüber gesprochen und da fiel dann auch, dass es den ganzen abhörenden Stellen eigentlich weniger um die Inhalte der ganzen Geschichte geht, sondern mehr um die Vernetzung untereinander. Also das heißt, wenn da jemand abgehört wird, dann interessieren die sich mehr in was für einer Community, der sich jetzt bewegt, was der eigentlich für Kumpels hat und was er vielleicht im Zweifelsfall dann mit denen zu tun hat. Aber damit man ungefähr weiß, in was für einem Netzwerk, der unterwegs ist. Also das geht ja viel, viel schneller und wird viel, viel schneller größer, zum Beispiel als bei Telefonabhörerei. Irgendwann hat man dann doch alle, oder? Ich meine, wenn man das immer noch auswählt, ich weiß ja nicht, auf wie viel Stufen das, ne? So Freunde zweiter, dritter Instanz und Freunde von Freunden, das geht doch ratzfatz. Da hat man doch im Grunde alle im Raster, oder nicht?
Ja, das ist halt die Hauptkritik an diesen Überwachungsmaßnahmen generell, dass es halt jeden trifft. Also jeder, der mit der Person kommuniziert, wird halt mitüberwacht. Und da gibt es wiederum zwei Meinungen. Die eine sagt halt, es gibt einfach eine Privatsphäre, deshalb ist Überwachung grundsätzlich von übel. Dass da Kriminalität über diese Kommunikationswege erfolgt, muss ich hinnehmen, um dieses höhere Gut, nämlich die Freiheit der Kommunikation und dieses Vermeideneinwissen zu machen. Die andere Meinung ist natürlich die, die sagen, okay, das ist zwar misslich, dass die mitüberwacht werden, aber eben wegen des übergeordneten Interesses der Strafverfolgung, nehmen wir das in Kauf und können das damit rechtfertigen, dass die Leute mit überwacht werden. Gegen die wird ja dann auch zumindest zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht ermittelt. Also das ist ja dann auch eine Unterscheidung, die man machen muss. Also das ist dann, aber da kommen wir sehr schnell in, eigentlich von fast, wie soll man sagen, ethische Fragen rein, staatsphilosophische Fragen rein.
Nicht weniger wird hier heute Abend diskutiert. Das wollen wir ja im Grunde auch ein bisschen immer mitschwingen lassen. Es geht uns ja ums Menschliche, also es hört sich ja immer zutiefst unmenschlich an, um über was geredet wird im Chaosradio, aber im Endeffekt geht es natürlich dann doch wieder um den Menschen. Am Telefon ist der Sebastian aus Hohen Saaten, wenn ich das richtig lese. Hallo Sebastian.
Ich habe eine Frage, ob man auch die kompletten FTP-Servern so ausspielen kann.
Da muss man vielleicht nochmal ausholen an der Stelle, dass diese, wie ich auch schon gesagt hatte, generell kann jede Form der Kommunikation abgehört werden. Das Neue, was wir jetzt nur haben ab 1.1. ist, dass es spezifizierte Schnittstellen und Übergabepunkte und Verfahren gibt, wie abgehört wird, was es den berechtigten Stellen leichter macht und auch schneller an die Daten heranzukommen. Aber unabhängig davon, was das für ein Protokoll ist, ob das jetzt FTP ist oder web oder was auch immer, das Recht abzuhören besteht in jedem Fall.
Richtig. Also auch der IP-Access, da gibt es zwar auch noch keine standardisierte Regelung für, aber es gibt ein vorläufiges Verfahren. Auch der IP-Access, also der sogenannte teilnehmerbezogene Internetzugang in Fachdeutsch, das wäre also der DSL Zugang zum Beispiel, kann überwacht werden und da gibt es auch Regelungen für. Und das ist auch bei den meisten schon geregelt. Der Zugang per Modem oder per Telefon ist Gegenstand der normalen Telefonüberwachung. Auch ISDN, ja, weil das ist ja eine Telefonverbindung, ob ich da jetzt reinspreche oder ob mein Modem da rein pfeift, ist sich vom Technik her relativ egal.
Ja, ISDN ist sogar noch einfacher, weil da liegt es ja eh schon digital vor.
In die Richtung geht vielleicht auch die Frage vom Charlie. Hallo Charlie.
Hallo.
Tachchen. Du willst auch wissen, wie komplett das Ganze ist, ne?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage, ob das jetzt nur die Sachen betrifft, die man jetzt direkt im Internet versendet und so, oder ob man jetzt auf dem Bild was man mit der Webcam macht und nur auf der Festplatte abspeichert, ob das auch gesehen werden kann oder halt ein Dokument, ob das geöffnet werden kann.
Nein, es geht rein um die Kommunikation. Also alles, was du nicht nach außen kommunizierst, kann auch nicht abgehört werden, ja. Also da werden von den Behörden keine Spyware-Programme auf deinem Rechner installiert oder so. Das ist nicht der Fall. Das ist auch ansonsten festgelegt in den rechtlichen Grundlagen, dass es keine Rückwirkung von den Abhörern auf deine Kommunikation gibt. Das heißt, die können das nicht verändern, die können keine E-Mails löschen, die können dir nichts vorenthalten, die können nichts manipulieren, was auch immer.
Aber um auf das Beispiel zurückzukommen, Entschuldigung, wenn du das Bild per MMS verschickst, also ein Bild machst und per MMS verschickst und gegen dich wird ermittelt und du wirst abgehört, dann kann die MMS auch abgefangen werden, ja.
Achso, aber jetzt ein Bild, was ich so mache, das kann man sich nicht einfach so runterziehen?
Nein, nicht auf dem Gerät. Also das Überwachen von Geräten ist eine ganz andere Geschichte. Das ist auch eine wesentlich höhere Hürde. Das fällt dann schon unter diesen großen Lauschangriff, wo er verschieben ist.
Das ist ja.
In bestimmten Fällen ja. Also es gibt auch im Rahmen, aber das sind wie gesagt höhere Hürden.
Also das ist die Rechtslage. Ich höre irgendwann nur so großer Lauschangriff, Telefon kann man abhören. Und jetzt ist halt wie gesagt auch das Internet so. Dann dachte ich mir, naja, das ist ja wohl ein bisschen ernst und krass, so überall Wanzen und so. Ich meine, das fällt dann auch unter die Kategorie, wie Wanzen irgendwo in eine Wohnung legen, so in der Art.
Also gerade beim Mobiltelefon gibt es ja noch die Spezialkategorie, die sogenannte stille SMS, die jetzt indirekt noch was mit dem Thema zu tun hat, aber die natürlich dazu gedacht ist, um deinen Aufenthaltsort festzustellen. Das heißt also, da wird quasi künstlich eine Kommunikation erzeugt mit deinem Mobiltelefon. Also das ist, da schickt dir die Polizei, wenn sie dich gegen dich ermittelt, können sie dir eine SMS schicken. Damit wird quasi künstlich eine Kommunikation aufgebaut. Davon merkst du aber nichts. Du siehst diese SMS nicht, sondern die kommt einfach nur bei deinem Telefon an, wird vom Telefon bestätigt. Und damit fallen aber diese Verbindungsdaten an, die dann wieder entsprechend ausgewertet werden können. Und bei Mobilfunktelefonen fällt eben auch der Standort des Telefons an. Das ist also technisch bedingt, der muss mitgespeichert werden oder ist halt im System vorhanden und muss auch bei so einer Anordnung dann mit übermittelt werden.
Ich hab ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten damit, muss ich ehrlich sagen, weil so die Kommunikation, die sich so etabliert hat und die man übers Internet, die fast jeder mittlerweile macht, einfach unbeschwerter ist, als z.B. Kommunikation per Brief. Also bevor ich in einen Brief das reinschreibe, was ich z.B. manchen Members im Forum an den Kopf schmeiße, wie z.B. glaubst du, du bist so bescheuert usw. man denkt immer nicht, dass das im Grunde zuordnbar ist, weil es ist eben halt nicht so an einen gebunden. Aber das ist es jetzt umso mehr, im Grunde auch durch solche Sachen.
Und es ist ja auch so, dass aus Sicht aller Beteiligten des Internet und die Kommunikation darüber in gewisser Weise erwachsen geworden sind. Also Telefon gibt es seit 100 Jahren und es ist halt eine alte Technik und es ist eine erwachsene Technik. Also man weiß, wenn man das Telefon in die Hand nimmt, hat man irgendwie ein Stück Geschichte in der Hand. Und das Internet und die ganze Industrie darum wird jetzt eben auch als erwachsen betrachtet. Und deswegen wird mehr und mehr auch bei der Regulierung gesagt, das ist eine Erwachsenindustrie, die verdient richtig Geld. Deshalb muss auch reguliert werden und sich rechtlichen Regeln unterwerfen, wie die anderen Kommunikationsindustrie, sprich Sprachtelefonie und Ähnliches auch.
Wir haben ja in der deutschen Wikipedia eine Mitmachseite zur Sendung. Die findet ihr unter dem Suchbegriff Chaosradio und den Link zur Sendung 99. Da sind auch schon jede Menge Fragen eingetragen worden. Da gibt es mittlerweile eine ganze Liste. Und ich würde gerne mal versuchen, dass wir die so mal im Laufe der Sendung so nach und nach abhaken. Und die erste ist also die Frage, ob jetzt generell im gesamten Datenstrom dieser E-Mails nach irgendwelchen Stichwörtern gesucht wird oder ob sich so eine Anordnung, so eine Maßnahme gegen einen Zugang richtet. Ich meine, man kann mal klar beantworten, es ist also mal gegen eine Person, gegen einen Account, gegen einen E-Mail-Account, gegen einen DSL-Anschluss. Das ist also nicht so, dass da wie irgendwie bei so einem System wie Echolon zum Beispiel oder Carnivore, wo einfach der gesamte Datenverkehr nach Stichwörtern überwacht wird. Das ist also bei der Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung, über die wir jetzt reden, ist also nicht der Fall. Und dann geht es wirklich um einzelne Anschlüsse, Zugänge.
Oder noch genauer, um die Bereitstellung einer Kopie der Telekommunikation. Was ist es eigentlich? Also es wird eine Kopie bereitgestellt, einer berechtigten Stelle.
Es soll also jetzt nicht großflächig nach irgendwelchen Stichwörtern oder so was gefiltert werden oder nach irgendwelchen bestimmten Dienstnullerprotokollen, sondern es geht einfach gezielt darum, auf die Daten von einem User von einem Benutzer zuzugreifen.
Ihr könnt anrufen unter 0317 77 91 10 mitmachen beim Chaosradio. Und der nächste in der Runde, jetzt muss ich mich kurz orientieren, ist der Thorsten. Hallo Thorsten.
Ja hallo.
Aus Berlin, nabend. Dein Statement zu dem Thema.
Ja, sicherlich ist es richtig, dass es halt immer wieder neue Ansätze gibt zur Überwachung, aber das Problem ist halt schon zwischen großem und kleinem Vergehen zu unterscheiden. Und wenn halt ein System oder erstmal eine Prozedur irgendwie eingeführt wird, dann betrifft es natürlich auch immer die kleinen Vergehen. Und das sehe ich halt schon als Problem. Also nicht nur in der Computerbranche, sondern in jedem Bereich.
Ja, ist sicherlich ein generelles, ob das jetzt hier in dem Fall zutrifft oder nicht, das wird sich ja erst die Zeit zeigen. Also man könnte ja irgendwie vielleicht noch sagen, die persönliche Schmerzgrenze ist da, wo im Moment diese Katalogstraftaten stehen. Das muss natürlich wieder mit sich ausmachen, ob das für ihn schon die Schmerzgrenze verschweidet, aber wann sowas gerechtfertigt ist oder nicht.
Was ist da alles dabei bei diesen Katalogstraftaten?
Das kann man wunderbar mal bei Google eingeben. Einfach Katalogstraftaten als Suchbegriff, der gerade mal irgendwie ein Internet zur Hand hat. Und da ist glaube ich der erste Hit, eine Seite von einer Rechtsanwaltskanzlei, die diesen Begriff sehr treffend erläutert und den auch gleich entsprechenden Hinweis gibt, wie die Hilfskonstruktion ist. Falls gerade mal keine dieser Katalogstraftaten zutrifft, dann versucht man zu sagen, naja, das ist eine kriminelle Vereinigung und ist damit dann wieder eine Katalogstraftat. Also das ist nicht die Seite, aber...
Also ich hab's hier auch vor mir. Also wenn man sich das mal durchliest, da sind schon ziemliche Klopper drin. Das ist halt die ganze Geschichte. Alles, was vorne im Strafgesetzbuch steht, das heißt Landesverrat, Hochverrat, diese ganzen Geschichten, dann die ganzen Verbrechen, also Mord, Totschlag, Völkermord, diese ganzen Sachen. Dann Geldwäsche, Verstoß gegen Betäubungsmittelgesetz, Verstoß gegen Waffengesetz. Und es ist auch von der Statistik her so, dass die weit überwiegende Mehrzahl der Anordnung wegen Verstoßes gegen das Betäubungsmittelgesetz erfolgt.
Die ganzen Kiffler.
Thorsten, war's das?
Na ja gut, aber daraufhin möchte ich halt gerne sagen, dass sicherlich die Großen, diejenigen, die halt wirklich bewusst in das Straftat eingehen oder begehen, dass die sich mit diesen neuen Mechanismen oder auf diese neuen Mechanismen sich besser einstellen können. Und Kleinere, die halt nichts damit zu tun haben eigentlich, die halt dummerweise, sagen wir mal, in der Straftat begangen haben oder eingelickt, dass die sich halt weniger schützen können. Und letztendlich fällt es immer wieder, wie in jedem anderen Bereich auch, immer auf die Kleinen zurück, dass halt mehr oder weniger durch diese neuen Verfahren nur die minderwertigen Kriminellen oder kriminalistisch begabten Menschen irgendwie erfasst werden, aber nicht die, die halt wirklich eine Straftat begehen wollen.
Das hat jetzt mit der elektronischen Überwachung eigentlich nichts zu tun, sondern es ist ein generelles Prinzip. Du kannst dich bei einem Bankraub irgendwie geschickt anstellen und du kannst dich vorher gut informieren über die Alarmanlagen und über was weiß ich was alles und kannst das irgendwie gut durchziehen oder du kannst irgendwie dumm sein und sofort verhaftet werden, weil du irgendwas falsch machst. Also das ist denke ich überall so. Und jetzt mit der Kommunikation ist es natürlich so, die Leute, die sich entsprechend auskennen, die wissen, wie sie zu verschlüsseln haben und was sie zu machen haben und welche Mittel und Wege sie benutzen, um den Inhalt und auch die Identität der beiden Kommunikationspartner zu verschleiern bzw. zu verschlüsseln.
Aber ich glaube, da kann man eine Lanze für die Polizei brechen. Sie verfolgt die Dummen wie die Schlauen. Ich glaube, da macht sie keinen großen Unterschied. Der Erfolg ist dann wahrscheinlich ein anderer. Aber das ist richtig. Das ist natürlich eine große Organisation. Organisationen, die, was weiß ich, wie viele Millionen Euro im Jahr Umsatz machen mit ihren Nachenschaften, ganz andere Mittel zur Verfügung haben, als wenn einer jetzt mal so eben in seinem Häuserblock irgendwie eine Tüte irgendwas verkauft.
Aber gut, die Sorge vom Thorsten kann ich mir schon erklären auch für mich, dass ich dann aus Versehen vielleicht irgendwas mache, was irgendwie nicht rechtens ist, und dann falle ich in irgendein Raster und zack, werd erwischt, obwohl ich eigentlich gar nichts Böses machen wollte und bin eigentlich Staatsbürger, der gar nichts Böses getan hat. Aber dann werde ich halt erwischt, weil das aus Versehen irgendwie in das Raster gefallen ist.
Das ist ja der Sinn des Richtervorbehaltes, dass nicht die Polizei oder der Staatsanwalt im Jagdfieber jetzt sagt, hey, hier haben wir einen, den nehmen wir uns jetzt, sondern dass dann ein Richter drüber guckt und sagt, und das nochmal prüft und sagt, ist das tatsächlich so? Und der diese Messensentscheidung durchführt und das im Ernstfall auch ablehnen kann.
Gibt es denn eine Verhältniszahl von Anträgen in diesem Bereich?
Und abgelehnten Anträgen? Es gibt Zahlen darüber, das ist glaube ich auch in der Max-Planck-Studie steht das drin. Und die Zahlen sind eher erschütternd.
Erschütternd hoch oder erschütternd niedrig?
Naja, also es ist so, dass die Sachen wirklich teilweise fast blanko unterschrieben werden. Also da gibt es sehr starke Kritik an der Praxis. Wir packen das mal mit in die Linksammlung. Das ist auf der Wikipedia-Seite, glaube ich, ist das auch schon verlinkt, diese Studie. Die ist wirklich so eine schlechte Launestudie eigentlich. Also wenn man die genauer sieht, ist halt auch von Juristen geschrieben. Ist halt sehr trocken, muss man sich antun. Aber es spiegelt eigentlich das wieder, was eigentlich auch die Zahlen der Abhörmaßnahmen belegen. Also es sieht dann nicht so gut aus um diesen Richthaftvorbehalt. Und also anzumerken wäre noch, dass also natürlich so eine Überwachungsmaßnahme ja eigentlich auch das allerletzte Mittel sein sollte. Das heißt also wenn nichts mehr greift, wenn alle das Haus überwachen, die Leute beschatten, was auch immer, irgendwelche Fingerabdrücke analysieren, wenn das alles fehlschlägt, dann aber auch nur dann als allerletzes Mittel soll diese Überwachung genutzt werden.
Natürlich die preiswertere Maßnahme eigentlich damit anzufangen, ne? Eben.
Es verleitet dazu, gerade wenn es jetzt mittlerweile möglich ist, einfach per Mausklick oder fast per Mausklick so eine Anordnung einzurichten oder mit ganz, ganz einfachen Mitteln. Und ich kann das dann wirklich an meinem PC, am Schreibtisch aussehen, wie die E-Mails durchscrollen. Das ist natürlich sehr verlockend, ja.
Thorsten? Ja? Noch Anmerkungen oder?
Na höchstens die einzige Anmerkung, dass euer Thema heute auf jedes andere Thema übertragbar wäre. Also heute ist zwar Elektronik oder die elektronischen Medien sind halt heute das Thema, aber man muss einfach mal genau diese ganzen ethischen Hintergründe auch auf andere Themen mal beziehen. Und das war eigentlich nur mein einziger Punkt gewesen, um da nochmal so ein bisschen nachzuhaken, dass es ja in anderen Bereichen genauso schwierig ist. Und dass man, wenn man jetzt in einem Bereich ist und den diskutiert und sagt, ja ist ja eigentlich legitim, dass man eigentlich normalerweise auch andere Bereiche, von mir aus DNA oder Videokameraüberwachung auf öffentlichen Plätzen, dass man halt alles normale hinterfragen müsste.
Das ist richtig, das tun wir auch als Chaos Computer Club. Wir beschäftigen uns mit Videoüberwachung, mit dem digitalen Tachographen, mit den Daten, die bei Tollcollect anfallen, mit der Biometrie in den Ausweisdokumenten, mit der elektronischen Gesundheitskarte, mit was weiß ich was alles.
Das Problem ist einfach, dass die gesellschaftliche Diskussion eben, was genau, was ist akzeptabel, was ist angemessen an Maßnahmen, was sollte in diesem Straftatenkatalog sein, was ist akzeptabel, wie ist diese Verhältnismäßigkeit gegeben. Auch bei der Videoüberwachung geht es jetzt darum, wenn ich da so ein paar Drogendealer mal von einem Platz vertreiben will, ist es angemessen, deswegen die ganze Innenstadt mit Videos überwachen zum Beispiel. Genau diese Diskussion findet in der Gesellschaft und auch in der Politik im Dialog mit der Gesellschaft leider nicht so statt, wie wir uns das wünschen würden. Ja genau, das ist gerade mein Punkt gewesen.
Vorhin nehm ich auch zum Beispiel DNA-Analyse oder halt DNA-Fingerabdruck. Hab ich vor kurzem erst in der süddeutschen Zeitung halt einen Artikel gelesen, dass halt Bayern den Vorschluss machen möchte, was halt gar nicht mal so verkehrt ist. Aber weil da kommt eigentlich schon wieder die Diskussion auf. Ja gut, wen betrifft es denn eigentlich wieder? Ja eigentlich will man die Großen oder die Schlimmthäter fassen. Aber letztendlich kommen dann doch wieder kleinere Delikte irgendwie eher zum Vorstellen oder zutage. Und genau das ist im Prinzip wie bei der Steuerpolitik. Also letztendlich muss immer der Kleine muss dann immer zahlen, wenn irgendwas Großes angeleiert wird, was Neues.
Thorsten, es ist gut, dass du es ansprichst, aber ich bremse an der Stelle einfach mal, weil wir uns ja wirklich in verschiedensten Chaosradio-Sendungen auch mit den Facetten dieses Themas auseinandergesetzt haben und das auch weiterhin tun werden. Uns heute aber mal wirklich an diesem Punkt hier ausruhen möchten und dann sagen möchten, das behandeln wir drei Stunden. Deswegen wollen wir es jetzt nicht zu weit werden lassen, weil wenn du jetzt schwadronierst, dann könnte es passieren, dass ganz viele andere Leute anrufen, dazu auch noch was sagen wollen. Dann sind wir ganz, ganz schnell wieder viel zu breit gefächert. Wobei Schwadronieren jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu negativ klang. Wir finden es ja prima, wenn da das breite Bewusstsein geschaffen wird und ihr euch irgendwie angeregt fühlt, euch auf breiter Front mit diesem Thema zu beschäftigen. Ihr hört das Chaosradio auf Fritz. Noch 2 Stunden Talk zum Thema Lauschangriff und Co. Und Co. ist in diesem Fall interessant, weil da geht es jetzt um E-Mail und alles, was an elektronischer Kommunikation hinten dran hängt. Wir trinken kurz einen Schluck. Ihr könnt weiter anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Der Blumuna Fritz hier, Chaosradio heute Abend. Thema Lauschangriff und zwar der elektronische, den gibt es nämlich ab diesem Jahr. Das heißt, E-Mail und elektronische Kommunikation aller Art, nämlich nicht nur noch Telefon, können jetzt abgehört werden, wenn der entsprechende Richter seinen Wilhelm macht unter dem Papier. Das macht ein Richter ja mal schneller oder mal weniger schnell. Deswegen ist das Ganze auch zu kritisieren, sowohl von User-Seite als auch von der Seite der Macher, weil alle, die irgendwas anbieten in der elektronischen Richtung, also euch elektronische Kommunikation bereitstellen, das was ihr so kennt, ist euer Internet Service Provider, die sind verpflichtet eben halt den entsprechenden Stellen, die das haben wollen, da auch den Anschluss bereitzustellen und die eben halt quasi ans Futter dran zu lassen. Und da wird es richtig spannend.
Wir wollen euch erzählen, wie das genau technisch um einst funktioniert. Das heißt, wie dieser technische Vorgang ist, dass so eine Überwachungsmaßnahme angeordnet wird. Merke ich was als User davon, erfährt der Provider was davon? Guckt er mich dann möglicherweise das nächste Mal komisch an, wenn ich da anrufe oder so, macht er dann irgendwie so eine komischen, schnippigen Bemerkungen oder so was. Oder wie muss ich mit so was rechnen? Was denkt ihr da drüber? Wie viel fühlt ihr euch, wenn ihr wisst, dass eure E-Mails möglicherweise von Polizeibeamten oder jemandem gelesen werden, von anderen Leuten? Wie sicher sind eigentlich diese E-Mails, diese Überwachungsmaßnahmen? Können diese Daten dann von Hackern gelesen werden? Oder kann der Internetprovider, werden die denn da am schwarzen Brett aufgehangen, die Daten? Oder was passiert mit diesen Daten, wenn sie denn abgehört worden sind? Das sind so Themen, die wir jetzt hier in einem nächsten Blog behandeln wollen.
Der Tim hat angerufen aus Berlin, Prenzlauer Berg, namens... Du hast dir da schon etwas speziellere Formen der Kommunikation rausgesucht, ne?
Und ich hab mich von Anfang an zugehört.
Hattest du, dass die jetzt nach einzelnen Wörtern suchen? Und wenn die Wörter vorkommen, hast du dich jetzt...
Es geht um die Überwachung einzelner User bzw. einzelner User-Accounts, aufrichterliche Anordnung. Es geht nicht um pauschale Durchsuchung nach Schlüsselwörtern von jeglichem Content.
Und wie komm ich jetzt in den Verdacht, dass wenn ich jetzt auf der Straße mit einem Kilo Gras erwische oder sowas, dann überprüfen sie mich, oder?
Dann nehmen die dich mit, weil du hast ja ein Kilo Gras dabei.
Wie komm ich in die Liste rein, in die verdächtigen Liste?
Sie könnten trotzdem irgendwie erst mal sehen, ah, der hat Gras, woher bekommt er denn das? Hören wir doch mal ab, mit wem der so telefoniert und wann der irgendwie die Übergabe dieses Grases vereinbart. Also es kann schon sein.
Das heißt, sie werden es erstmal nicht abnehmen, sondern werden erstmal gucken, wen rufst du an, oder in dem Moment, wo du es bekommen hast, weißt du, wen rufst du als nächstes an, wem schreibst du als nächstes irgendwie einen Instant Message oder wem schickst du eine SMS. Das sind gerade die interessanten Daten, die dabei anfallen. Es geht nicht mehr darum, ob das jetzt irgendwie Polle oder schwarze Afghane ist, das vielleicht auch, aber das ist nebensächlich, sondern es geht darum, wen rufst du als nächstes an.
Ja, und nicht nur wen, sondern was sagst du zu dem, beziehungsweise was schreibst du in der E-Mail? Es ist ja nicht nur die Verbindung, sondern auch der Inhalt der Information, der Kommunikation.
Haben die dann so meinen ganzen Monitor auf ihrem Display?
Oder müssen die die Programme kennen?
Oder wenn jetzt ein Kumpel von mir sein eigenes Programm schreibt, und ich dann mit dem über das Programm kommuniziere, sehen die das dann trotzdem oder geht es dann nach dem Programm? Ich sehe es noch nicht so, dass das Ding... Sie haben die denn, weiß ich, genau mein Display bei sich drauf?
Oder wie verfolgen die das?
Nein, es geht einfach darum, dass der Internetprovider oder der Betreiber dieser Telekommunikationsanlage, Server, eine Schnittstelle bereitstellt, wo man den Traffic der Leute, die abgehört werden, kopieren kann und über eine Infrastruktur bereitstellen kann. Da gibt es natürlich eine gewisse Grenze in der technischen Machbarkeit. Und diese im Moment noch bei ICQ und bei solchen Sachen, das ist einfach technisch nicht machbar, weil es einfach viel zu viel Traffic ist und man das auch nicht richtig erfassen kann. Das ist eine Sache, die im Moment, soweit ich das weiß, nicht überwacht wird oder wenn dann nur im Einzelfall.
Wobei die Protokolle jetzt auch nicht besonders exotisch sind, oder?
Ja, da geht es aber mehr ums Volumen. Da ist es teilweise ein echtes Problem. Bei E-Mail ist es dann so, um den Fall zu nehmen, der jetzt ab 1. Januar auch konkret geregelt ist und standardisiert ist, da wird der E-Mail Server des Providers so verändert, dass er eine Schnittstelle hat, wo ich dann zum Beispiel den Traffic oder die Ereignisse einer Mailbox eines Users kopieren und aufarbeiten und ausleiten kann an die Strafverfolgungsbehörde zum Beispiel. Das heißt, es muss man sich auch wirklich so vorstellen, es gibt auch keine Rückwirkung auf den E-Mail Server, das heißt, es darf auch nicht so sein, dass der Nutzer das mitkriegt oder sogar, dass der Dienst dadurch langsamer oder schlechter wird, sondern es muss einfach fast, also rückwirkungsfrei, muss einfach eine Kopie hergestellt werden dessen, was auf dem Server passiert.
Das heißt also, weder der Nutzer, also du als Kunde, noch auch der Internetprovider dürfen irgendwas davon mitkriegen?
Na, der Internetprovider kriegt das schon mit. Der muss es ja einschalten.
Von den Inhalten.
Von den Inhalten nicht.
Und bei dem Internetprovider ist es auch so, dass die Systeme so konfiguriert sein müssen, dass Eingriffe in das System nutzerbezogen gelockt werden. Das heißt, es ist auch spezielles Personal. Das darf nicht jeder beim Internetprovider. Und auch diese Eingriffe in das System müssen entsprechend protokolliert werden und in Quartalsberichten etc. auch berichtet werden. Also das wird schon sehr streng gehandhabt, auch organisatorisch. Es gibt auch eine strenge Rollentrennung. Das heißt, man unterscheidet zwischen den Leuten, die die Überwachungsmaßnahmen eigentlich bearbeiten, und demjenigen oder derjenigen, die dann die Protokolle prüft. Also derjenige, der eine Überwachungsmaßnahme bearbeitet, darf zum Beispiel nicht die Protokolle manipulieren können. Das System muss so eingerichtet sein, sodass da auch zumindest organisatorische Vorsichtsmaßnahmen getroffen werden, dass nicht einfach der Fall auftritt, wir hängen das jetzt mal in einer Kantine an ein schwarzes Brett und lachen uns eins. Das ist schon sehr streng geregelt. Also da gibt es durchaus auch sowohl von den Systemen her, als auch von der Organisation her deutliche Regeln, wer was machen darf.
Und es noch sehr, sehr strenge Regeln vorgegeben, wie genau die Daten verschlüsselt werden, wenn sie an die Behörden übermittelt werden. Da gibt es also eine klare Ansage, da müssen spezielle Geräte stehen, die diese Verbindung verschlüsseln. Das heißt, dass auch nicht jemand einfach an diesen Zugang rein kann.
Ja, das ist also für diejenigen, die etwas technisch sind, können wir das auch mal in zwei, drei Worten erklären, was da passiert. Die machen also im Grunde ein Standard-VPN, also ein IPSEC. Allerdings der Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus, den sie verwenden, ist ein nicht öffentlich dokumentierter und nicht bekannter, der nennt sich Libelle. Und da gibt es einen speziellen... Libelle! Libelle! Ja, dieses fliegende kleine... Du weißt schon. Und da gibt es einen speziellen Chip, der wurde von Infineon gefertigt und ist irgendwie spezifiziert vom Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik. Und der implementiert eben diesen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus und verschlüsselt dann eben die Daten.
Und hat der Chaos Computer Club den schon gehackt?
Wir haben ihn nicht mehr in die Hand bekommen.
Gut, ich hatte jetzt mehr erwartet.
Du weißt ja, wir machen das... Wir kriegen ja höchstens anonyme Berichte.
Richtig, natürlich. Klar, ihr macht ja selber gar nichts. Macht ja... Das machen ja immer andere, die sich dann melden. Gut, Tim, Frage beantwortet zur Zufriedenheit. Ich meine, Angst kann man dir jetzt nicht nehmen oder Sorge?
Eine Frage habe ich noch kurz. Gibt es jetzt schon Klagen vom Verfassungsgericht oder sowas? Deswegen gibt es ja schon Leute, die da irgendwie jetzt klagen, oder gibt es da noch gar nichts?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste im Moment.
Und dann noch eine Frage an Max.
Kannst du mir die URL von deinem Clan schicken?
Oder jetzt ansagen oder so? Wir haben eine öffentlich zugängliche Seite. Da wir etwas älterer Natur sind, also da wir ja... Das hat jetzt natürlich erst jetzt Zocker enttarnt. Das kann jetzt natürlich keiner weitergeben.
40 plus, ja.
Nein, nicht 40 plus. Ich meine, wenn man älter als 18 ist, gehört man zum alten Eisen. Deswegen heißt unsere Gilde altes Eisen zu finden unter www.eisenalt.de Mit Bindestrich oder einfach... Ohne Bindestrich. Es ist quasi als adäktiv zu verstehen.
Okay, danke.
Kannst du gerne vorbeischauen, ne?
Ja, zu dieser Verfassungsgerichtssache vielleicht noch eine Anmerkung. Also rein rechtlich, juristisch hat sich jetzt nichts geändert zum 1.1. Es hat sich nur eine Richtlinie zur Verordnung zum Gesetz spezifiziert und ist wirksam geworden. Also, ja, das ist ja so eine ganze Hierarchie. Da gibt es das Telekommunikationsgesetz und dann gibt es die Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung. Ein wunderschönes Wort. Und dann die technische Richtlinie zur Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung für die einzelnen Telekommunikationstechnologien. Also für ISDN, für GSM, also Mobiltelefone, für E-Mails und dann jetzt eben im Laufe dieses Jahres soll es dann auch die technischen Richtlinien für Voice-over-IP und für Teilnehmer, also DSL-Anschlüsse dergleichen, Breitbandzugänge. Was soll doch dieses Jahr kommen?
Und WLAN, also zumindest vorläufige Regelungen in der technischen Richtlinie sollen gefunden werden. Das findet man auch alles auf der Seite der Regulierungsbehörde. Unter den öffentlichen Anhörungen, da steht nämlich der Vorhabensplan der Regulierungsbehörde für das Jahr 2005 und da gibt es einen Abschnitt öffentliche Sicherheit. Und da steht auch alles drin, was die Regulierungsbehörde für dieses Jahr machen will. Die Regulierungsbehörde ist überhaupt, da sehr, also alle diese Dokumente, alles was wir besprechen, findet man auf der Seite der Regulierungsbehörde. Unter technische Regulierung der Telekommunikation, wenn man da reingeht. Und da gibt es ganz unten einen Abschnitt technische Umsetzung von Überwachungsmaßnahmen. Da findet man alle Dokumente darum, auch die technische Richtlinie, die Gesetze, alles andere.
Ganz kurze Zwischenfrage, weil wir vorhin ja auch bei dem Thema ist da schon jemand vor das Verfassungsgericht gegangen war und so. Was ja sehr wichtig ist in letzter Zeit ist immer, was wird irgendwie in Deutschland entschieden, was wird EU-weit entschieden? Gibt es auf EU-Ebene irgendwas, wo an der Gesetzgebung gebastelt wird, dass wir irgendwie Hoffnung haben können, dass es in einem halben Jahr sowieso wieder was anderes übergestülpt wird? Oder geht genau das, was wir machen jetzt auch auf EU über, weil die das alle gut finden? Was ist da im Gange?
Also es ist ja so, dass in dem Bereich, gerade im Bereich des Telekommunikationsrechts, immer weniger nationales Recht ist. Es ist viel europäisches Recht. Es gibt das Richtlinienpaket, das neueste, das ist aus 2002 verabschiedet worden. Und das neue Telekommunikationsgesetz ist zum Beispiel in weiten Teilen die Umsetzung dieses Richtlinienpaketes. Und auch bei den Überwachungsmaßnahmen ist es so, es gibt die EZI. Das ist jetzt zwar auch wieder eine Abkürzung.
European Telecommunication Standardization Institute, genau.
Richtig, und die EZI kümmert sich halt um diese ganzen Sachen, die Telekommunikationsstandardisierung in der Europäischen Union und veröffentlicht halt europäische Standards und technische Empfehlungen, Technical Recommendations und es gibt innerhalb der EZI eine eigene Arbeitsgruppe, Lawful Interception, wie das im Englischen heißt. Und die legen halt entsprechende Richtlinien auf Fest- und Direkt-EP, also die Regulierungsbehörde, bezieht sich im Wesentlichen auch mehr und mehr auf diese technischen Empfehlungen der EZI.
Muss sie aber entsprechend auf die nationalen, also sprich auf die deutschen Gegebenheiten hier anpassen. Das heißt also, die wissen, was es bisher für Regulierung, für Regelungen gab, für Telekommunikationsanbieter, die wissen, welche Schnittstellen da sind. Die kennen die nationalen Befindlichkeiten hier entsprechend und dementsprechend werden also diese grundlegende Sachen EU-weit entschieden und müssen dann von den, in den Staaten, in einzelnen EU-Staaten dann entsprechend umgesetzt werden, in die Praxis umgesetzt werden. Das ist also auch eine Frage hier im Wikipedia. Da ist also die Frage, wie sieht es aus mit Österreich? Und können wir denke ich sagen, wird dann dementsprechend auch umgesetzt werden dort. Was mir vorhin noch so ein Gedanke gekommen ist, ich finde es ja fast ein bisschen zynisch, dass diese ganzen Dokumente da so öffentlich einsehbar sind. Also ich meine, das ist natürlich sehr lobenswert und sowas, aber andererseits, wenn ich mir das so durchlese, also ich kann halt durchlesen, in welchem XML-Format meine abgehörten E-Mails dann an die Behörden übermittelt werden. Also das ist ja schon so ein bisschen...
XML mit deutschen Texts.
Das ist das erste Mal in meinem Leben, dass ich sowas gesehen habe.
Also das ist ja im Prinzip, das finde ich sehr lobenswert, aber es gibt mir schon so irgendwie so ein komisches, flausches Gefühl im Bauch, wenn ich sowas so lese. Und ich lese halt wirklich haarklein genau, wie irgendwie, wie mein E-Mail-Header da eingepackt wird und wie die Sachen übermittelt werden und sowas.
Das ist ein bisschen wie ein Pornozugucken, in dem man aus Versehen selber mitgespielt hat.
Es ist irgendwie pervers. Aber gut, es gibt natürlich Fragen von euch. 0331 77 97 110. Wenn ihr Fragen habt, könnt ihr die stellen, wie zum Beispiel der Jan aus Berlin. Hallo Jan.
Ja, grüßt euch. Und wenn wir telefonieren, meint er, es wird immer mitgeschnitten. Beziehungsweise der Computer läuft immer mit. Und wenn Stichworte wie Heroin, Atombombe oder so fällt, dann wird der Computer angeschmissen und mitgeschnitten.
Wobei Heroin, Atombombe ein komisches Wort ist, aber lassen wir gelten.
Heroinbombe. Na, wir hatten das in der Versendung auch schon mehrfach erwähnt. Also jetzt bei uns hier, um das Thema der heutigen Sendung, die Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung, das ist also die gezielte auf richterliche Anordnung erfolgende Überwachung einzelner Teilnehmer bzw. einzelner Anschlüsse von Teilnehmern. Hat also nichts mit der pauschalen Durchsuchung und Überwachung von Content zu tun.
Das ist nicht Teil der Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung, über die wir heute Abend reden.
Sagen wir mal so, es gibt dieses berühmte Echelon, aber es gibt im Rahmen der Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung die Geschichten nach G10-Gesetz und des Außenwirtschaftsgesetzes. Und da gibt es durchaus Sachen der strategischen Überwachung. Da kann es auch durchaus Anordnungen geben, dass ich sämtlichen Traffic, der ins Ausland gehe, irgendwo aufzeichne und auswerte. Oder dass so eine Anordnung darauf lauten kann, sämtlicher Traffic, der von und nach Afghanistan geht oder sowas, wird überwacht. Das ist aber wirklich die absolute Ausnahme. Das sind Sachen, die auch einen hohen Aufwand vom Antrag her erfordern, zumindest in der Theorie, um sowas umzusetzen. Aber da muss man zwei Sachen unterscheiden. Das ist in der TKWV auch in einem zweiten Teil geregelt. Das ist dieses Verfahren nach G10. Das muss auch separat nochmal mit dem Bundesnachrichtendienst im Einzelfall geklärt werden, wie das passiert. Das betrifft aber nur die allerwenigsten Probeinahmen.
Noch eine Frage. Wie viele Leute arbeiten eigentlich in der ganzen Sache? Zum Beispiel in Berlin. Mit Überwachung von Internet, von Handy, von Kameras. Wie viele Leute arbeiten da? Zumindest 10.000 ist eins. In Berlin gibt es allein schon 600 Kameras zum Beispiel.
Kameras ist zwar wieder ein anderes Thema. Viele Kameras zeichnen eigentlich nur auf, wenn man nachgucken will. Da muss nicht wirklich jemand damit beschäftigt sein. Oder hängen nur zur Absteckung in der Videorekorder kaputt. Das gibt es auch. Aber jetzt rein auf die Telekommunikationsüberwachung, weiß ich nicht. Die tatsächliche Auswertung der überwachten Daten, das machen ja nur die berechtigten Stellen, also die Ermittlungsbehörden und wie viele Beamte dort im jeweiligen Dienst sind. Das weiß ich nicht, ob man da irgendwelche statistischen Zahlen findet. Wahrscheinlich, weiß ich aber nicht.
Aber ich glaube, in der letzten CT war mal ein Bild des Rechenzentrums des BKA. Das sah noch relativ überschaubar aus.
Das ist doch alles unterirdisch.
Ansonsten, man darf das auch nicht zu groß malen, was da jetzt aufgebaut worden ist. Also so viele Knoten gibt es in diesem VPM auch noch nicht.
Und vielleicht noch was mit dem Handy jetzt. Kann man es hören oder nicht? Man heißt es und es knackt und es knackt nicht und man hat es nicht abgehört, kann man es hören?
Völlig ausgeführt?
Definitiv nicht. Also es gab mal ein kleines Missgeschick von O2, was auch in die Geschichte eingegangen ist, der Abhörmaßnahmen, wo einem Abgehörten aus Versehen die Verbindungen zur Abhörstelle dann mit auf die Rechnung aufgedruckt wurden. Kostenmäßig, also wie gesagt, der Fall ist in die Geschichte eingegangen, war auch allen Beteiligten höchst peinlich und kommt mit Sicherheit nicht wieder vor.
Das darf also, ist auch gesetzlich eben vorgeschrieben, dass das in keinem Fall passieren darf.
Ich mach Fotos von Kameras übrigens, von Überwachungskameras, stelle mich auf die Leiter, fotografiere die immer.
Super.
Ich denke nur, welche Leute mich da anschauen.
www.ccc.de, wir machen gerade eine Umfrage zur Kameraüberwachung, wo ein Formbrief ist, ein Musterbrief, wo du den Kamerabetreiber um Auskunft bitten kannst.
So, der Stefan ist dran.
Hallo.
Stefan aus Stendal? Die Wartezeiten sind manchmal ein bisschen bei so komplizierten Fragen und Antworten ein bisschen größer, aber der Daniel dürfte dadurch in unser Überwachungsraster gerutscht sein. Hallo Daniel.
Ja, genau. Und zwar, ich komme jetzt euch mal mit ein bisschen einer technischen Sache. Und zwar die Frage, inwieweit man Verschlüsselungen jetzt einsetzen kann, beziehungsweise vor allen Dingen einsetzen sollte. Und zwar jetzt nicht nur, klar, PGP ist eine Sache, die kann man machen, wenn man Ahnung hat. Im Rahmen des 21.3. ist ja auch wieder praktiziert worden Signature Party. Die Frage ist, wie macht man das für die Masse? Weil, ich sag mal so, jemand, der es jetzt unbedingt vermeiden will, abgehört zu werden, kann es ja machen. Ist ja nicht das Problem. Die Frage ist, wie kann man so eine PKI etablieren, sag ich mal.
Ich denke, du sprichst von Sachen für die Massen.
Ja, der Witz ist, ich weiß, dass PKI ist jetzt nicht so, wo der Renner sind Usability mäßig. Es ist schon recht kompliziert. Die Idee ist aber eben, das so einfach wie möglich zu machen. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab hier eine andere Idee als eine PKI.
Das ganz große Problem dabei ist, dass wenn du sowas in einer Größenordnung aufziehst, dass es für mehrere tausend Nutzer ist, dann musst du den Behörden auch großer Wahrscheinlichkeit wieder einen unverschlüsselten Zugang zur Verfügung stellen. Das heißt also, die Maßnahme ist denn nutzlos. Das heißt also, wenn du das nicht nur mit ein paar Freunden machst?
Na also, vielleicht erst mal zur Erklärung. Es geht um Public Key Infrastructure. Also um die Infrastruktur für Asymetrische Verschlüsselungsverfahren. Ich denke, das ist einfach das Problem, dass wenn du so eine PKI hast, dann ist das eine zentrale Instanz, die zertifiziert. Das heißt, es gibt irgendwo eine Stelle, die sagt, ja dieser Schlüssel gehört tatsächlich zu Frank oder zu Jörg oder zu wem auch immer. Und je größer die wird, ich meine, wem vertraust du, wer soll diese Stelle sein? Du hast ein fundamentales Vertrauensproblem.
Ich sag mal so, demjenigen, dem ich anvertraue, dass er mir einen Pass ausstellt, der sollte zumindest in der Lage sein, mir auch so einen Schlüssel einzustellen. Und wenn ich doch jetzt einen RSA-Key oder so etwas habe, also so etwas, wo allgemein anerkannt ist, dass jetzt nicht ohne weiteres zwei Schlüssel möglich sind, korrigiere mich, wenn das nicht stimmt, dann kann ich dem eigentlich erst mal ein gewisses Maß an Vertrauen. Ich kann ja dann sicherlich noch Zusatzbedingungen einbauen. Also wenn ich total paranoid bin, sage ich natürlich, ich nehme nicht die offizielle PKI, sondern baue mir nebenbei was mit PGP auf. Aber das kommt ja dann auch immer darauf an, wie sicher muss es sein, bzw. vor wem muss ich mich schützen. Wenn ich mich jetzt vom Staat schützen will, habe ich natürlich so ein bisschen das Problem, kann ich dessen Zertifizierung vertrauen. Aber das ist ja dann bei Verschlüsselung wieder eine Sache. Kann ich diesem Verschlüsselungsverfahren vertrauen? Kann ich vertrauen, dass es keine zweiten Schlüssel zum Abhören gibt?
Ja, also da gibt es unglaublich viele Layer dieser Problematik, dass du es richtig dir da aufzeigst, da gibt es auch noch mehr. Aber ich meine, heute reden wir über die Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung und da geht es um den Staat, der abhört. Und da hilft mir es sicherlich nicht, wenn ich irgendwelche Verfahren verwende, bei denen mir der Staat irgendwas garantiert. Das ist also irgendwo ein gewisses Problem, ein gewisser Interessenskonflikt, der dann da wohl auftritt.
Und auch beim Staat natürlich auftritt. Also warum sollte der Staat sozusagen irgendwas unterstützen, was er ja quasi... Na, man ist doch schon.
Also wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, gibt es ja bereits alleine aus der Notwendigkeit heraus irgendwelche Strebungen, so was wie eine PKI aufzubauen.
Es gibt die Signaturkarten. Es gibt das Signaturgesetz und da gibt es Chipkarten, die dem Signaturgesetz entsprechen und da gibt es eine entsprechende Public-Key-Infrastruktur. Aber die Karte sagt auch schon, es ist eine Signaturkarte, und keine Verschlüsselungskarte. Natürlich kannst du jetzt anfangen, in ein System auszudenken. Ich denke, das würde auch möglich sein, technisch. Ein Verschlüsselungssystem basierend auf den Signaturschlüsseln zu machen, die in den Signaturkarten drin sind. Dann hättest du sozusagen irgendwie die PKI für die Signaturkarten kombiniert mit einem Verschlüsselungsverfahren, das sich daraus irgendwie ableitet. Aber der Staat selber profakiert das nicht. Natürlich gibt es Seiten, wie zum Beispiel das Bundesamt für Sicherheit und Informationstechnik hat ja diese Sicherheit im Internet, dieses Portal www.sicherheit-im-internet.de, wo auch drinsteht, dass man bei vertraulichen Dinge Verschlüsselung verwenden soll. Das ist natürlich klar. Ich meine, es gibt auf der einen Seite Teile des Staates, die versuchen auch der Wirtschaft zum Beispiel zu sagen, ja schützt euch verschlüsselt, damit niemand an eure Firmengeheimnisse rankommt. Vor allem keine, was weiß ich, wenn es um Industriefirmen geht, keine ausländischen Wirtschaftsspionage, sonst irgendwas. Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es natürlich, wenn dann irgendwas Illegales kommuniziert wird, dass man irgendwie überwachen möchte. Das ist ein Konflikt, der da ist. Und den würden wir auch nicht auflösen können.
Ich meine, im Zweifelsfall kann man natürlich immer noch auf PGP zurückgreifen. Dann ist aber natürlich wieder die Frage, wie kriegt man es massentauglich? Also der CCC und andere versuchen ja schon ihr Bestes, um es zu propagieren. Nur wenn ich mir solche Partys anschaue, treffe ich halt meistens die üblichen Verdächtigen.
Eine interessante Frage ist ja auch, kann zum Beispiel ein Provider sagen, oh, der Staat, wir haben eigentlich gar keine Lust mehr und wir bieten jetzt hier einfach eine flächendeckende Verschlüsselung an. Das heißt also einfach, wir bieten unseren Kunden komplett vollständige Mail-Verschlüsselung einfach an. Wäre das denn ein denkbares Szenario für dich?
Dann ist aber immer die Frage, also für mich wäre es halt wichtig, immer zu wissen, was steht technisch dahinter. Solange ich abschätzen kann, ob es für mich sicher ist, jetzt mal ohne jetzt eine konkrete Umsetzung sich zu überlegen, würde ich es mir überlegen. Aber es hängt halt immer sehr stark von der technischen Umsetzung.
Du kannst das ja bei PGP auch nicht abschätzen. Ich meine, alle sagen...
Na ja gut, man kann letztendlich, wenn man sich mathematisch runterrechnet, und selbst die Mathematiker sind sich da ja nicht ganz einig oder eigentlich überhaupt nicht einig, was die Sicherheit solcher asymetrischen Verfahren angeht.
Also die Mathematiker sind sich noch am ehesten einig. Viel mehr als die Programmierer zu mindestens. Oder die Leute, die sich den Code angucken.
Aber um nochmal die Überwachungsverordnung einzuwerfen zwischendurch. Wenn der Provider netzseitig verschlüsselt, dann muss er nach der neuen TKF auch das ganze unverschlüsselt zur Verfügung stellen können. Das heißt die netzseitige Verschlüsselung, die muss er immer wieder umkehren können.
Okay, also bleibt mir gar nichts anderes übrig als der Watzesverschlüsselung.
Was du sowieso tun solltest.
Dann nochmal ganz kurz noch eine andere Frage. Wenn ich jetzt als Provider, ich glaube unter 10.000 Nutzern, oder was war das?
Richtig.
Auftrete, muss ich dann meinem Übergartenprovider die Möglichkeit geben, etwas umleiten zu können oder bin ich dann völlig von diesen Maßnahmen befreit?
Nein, es gibt unter 10.000 eine Reihe von Einschränkungen. Also eine Reihe von Erleichterungen. Wir sind aber mehr organisatorischer Natur. Also ich muss nicht mehr 24-7 da sein und nicht mehr, also ich muss nicht mehr unverzüglich umsetzen, sondern habe eine gewisse Zeit. Also es sind vor allen Dingen organisatorische Erleichterungen.
Das heißt letztendlich bin ich genauso verpflichtet. Richtig. Dann müsste ich sie aber doch eigentlich auch vorhalten.
Inwiefern vorhalten?
Oder bezieht sich das wirklich nur an die Mails ab Beantragung einer Anordnung?
Das ist nur für die Zukunft. Also nicht so, wir hätten gerne die Anordnung und wir datieren die jetzt mal zwei Wochen zurück und hätten das gerne.
Vielleicht sollten wir an der Stelle noch mal auch beschreiben, wer denn eigentlich tatsächlich jetzt solche Schnittstellen schaffen muss. Das hatten wir bisher noch nicht.
Weil es viel grad so ab 10.000, da geht es dann auch um Userzahlen.
Ja, das ist halt jetzt so eine Geschichte, mit denen, wie diese Grenze zu definieren ist. Also die magische Grenze sind 1000 Teilnehmer oder wie wir in der neuen TKUV lesen können, also die dieses Jahr, jetzt Anfang des Jahres in Kraft tritt. 1000 Teilnehmer oder 1000 Nutzungsberechtigungen. So ein Teilnehmer ist per Definition eine natürliche oder heuristische Person, der ich eine Telekommunikationsleistung auf Basis eines Vertrages erbringe. Das könnte ja so sein, ich kann zwar 10.000 Leute an meinem Dienst, aber es sind nur 10 Firmen, also 10 Vertragspartner, sprich, ich muss nicht überwachen, weil ich habe nur 10 Teilnehmer. Da ist es aber wiederum so, dass die Nutzungsberechtigungen auf die Nutzer gehen. Und der Nutzer ist halt jemand, der die Sachen nutzt, ohne selbst Teilnehmer sein zu möchten. Also der muss keinen Vertrag haben. Da kommen wir dann wirklich in eine Grauzone rein. Weil da gibt es auch tausende an einen Einzelfall, wo man sich da nochmal das genauer angucken muss im Einzelfall.
Huja, wir atmen durch. Daniel, grüß nach Chemnitz. Wir machen jetzt mal kurz Nachrichten und erholen unsere kleinen Gehirne. Ja, dann viel Spaß noch.
Wenn Fritz in Wedding, dann Wunder 2, 6.
23.30 Uhr. Mit dem Wetter natürlich. In der Nacht Schnee, Regen, kann also glatt werden. Seit vorsichtige Temperaturen sinken auf 2 des Minus 1 Grad. Morgen zunehmend Regen bei Höchstwerten zwischen 6 und 8 Grad. Also nichts Berühmtes. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötterheim.
Verteidigungsminister Struck hat das Urteil des Bundesverwaltungsgerichts zur Wehrpflicht begrüßt. Die Richter in Leipzig hatten entschieden, dass die Einberufungspraxis rechtens ist. Ein 22-jähriger Student hatte sich ungerecht behandelt gefühlt. Bundeskanzler Schröder hat das Einstein Jahr 2005 eröffnet. An der Feier im Deutschen Historischen Museum in Berlin nahmen 800 Gäste teil. Schröder würdigte den Physiker als einen vorbildlichen Wissenschaftler. Einstein hatte vor 100 Jahren die Relativitätstheorie erfunden. In Indonesien hat sich die Zahl der Flutopfer stark erhöht. Die Regierung sprach von 50.000 Toten mehr. Damit kamen in Indonesien mindestens 166.000 Menschen ums Leben. Grund für den Anstieg sind Opferzahlen aus Gebieten, die bisher nicht zugänglich waren. Großbritanniens Premierminister Blair hat die Forderung irakischer Gefangener durch britische Soldaten verurteilt. Vor dem Parlament versicherte er die Schuldigenwürden zur Rechenschaft gezogen. Bekannt wurde der Skandal durch Fotos, die an die Öffentlichkeit gelangt sind. Der Verkehr, Herr Fritz, ist teilweise glatt auf den Straßen, bei Schneeregen gefriert es schnell, dann wird es gefährlich und fahrt vorsichtig alles Weitere. Äh, erzähl ich jetzt nicht mehr. Gute Fahrt.
Danke für diese Einschätzung, Gerald.
Tommy Walsh, Ihr aktuelles Bühnenprogramm trägt den Titel Walsh versus Gott. Es kann nur einen geben. Ist da nicht schon der Titel Blasphemie?
Die Frage irritiert mich, also Ihre Frage irritiert mich jetzt ein bisschen, denn ich habe ja ganz bewusst den Ausgang dieses Wettkampfs der beiden größten Showgiganten des Universums offen gelassen. Das wird sich ja dann erst vor Ort rausstellen. Ich bin sehr, sehr stolz darauf, dass wir auch diesmal wieder die Eintrittsgelder fast verdoppelt haben und die Witze halbiert.
Und zwar auf Fritz, das Chaos Radio hier, Halbzeit, wir haben es 23.30 Uhr, das heißt bis 1 Uhr noch anderthalb Stunden, könnt ihr mit uns quatschen. Thema heute Abend natürlich ein klassisches Chaos Computer Club Thema, nämlich Lauschangriff und zwar der erweiterte, der etwas größere, erwächst. Also man könnte natürlich auch sagen, er wird erwachsen damit, dass jetzt endlich die anderen elektronischen Medien mit einbezogen werden, also nicht nur noch Telefonen, sondern seit Ersten, Ersten diesen Jahres auch E-Mail und Co. wobei man sich über diese ganzen verschiedenen Protokolle noch nicht so im Klaren ist. Wir hatten heute Abend auch die Diskussion Instant Messenger, also wenn ich irgendwelche Nachrichten über ICQ, IAM oder was auch immer schicke, wird das auch überwacht. Können die das? Können die das nicht? Das ist alles noch nicht so ausgereift, aber man will da auf jeden Fall hin. Im Studio natürlich vom Chaos Computer Club, wieder zwei, der Harald und der Frank, Jörg, unser Gast, IT-Berater seines Zeichens, der sich also sehr viel damit der rechtlichen Seite auch beratet, auseinandersetzt. Und meine Person, der Max.
Da bist du wieder. Vor der Sendung, vor der Nachrichten sind wir stehen geblieben bei der Frage, wer ist dann eigentlich verpflichtet? Das heißt also, wie groß muss ein Provider sein? Welchen Rahmen muss das annehmen? Muss das jetzt ein riesengroßer Geschäftsbetrieb sein? Oder wie ist das, wenn ich jetzt einen eigenen kleinen Server habe? Spannend auch die Frage, wie ist das an Unis oder kleineren Firmen, Hotels, Krankenhäusern? Müssen die sowas anbieten? Werden die entsprechende Zugänge bieten? Wir auf dem Kongress müssen uns auch die Frage stellen als CCC. Wie ist das, wenn ich zum Beispiel eine LAN-Party veranstaltete? Eine große muss ich dann auch für die Herren in grün entsprechend so eine Ethernet-Dose vorhalten. Wie sieht das da aus? Vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz, ihr könnt mit uns Kontakt aufnehmen in vielfältigsten Methoden. Eine Variante ist eine Mail zu schreiben 99, also die Zahlen 99 at chaosradio.ccc.de. Das haben auch schon ziemlich viele Leute gemacht. Es geht vor allem dabei um Fragen zu PGP und Verschlüsselung. Da werden wir, denke ich, dem Thema später noch ein extra Blog widmen und dann noch mal eine kurze Einführung geben und darüber reden, wie sicher es alles ist und wie das funktioniert.
Dann gibt es bei uns auf der Seite von Fritz unter fritz.de den interaktiven Part, also da, wo ihr in die Boards schreiben könnt. Da habe ich mal ins Games und Multimedia Board einen kleinen Thread gepostet. Da wird auch schon reingeschrieben. Die Fragen, die da drin stehen, hatten wir heute Abend schon beantwortet zum Teil. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch Antworten von euch direkt. Da brauchen wir jetzt nicht näher darauf einzugehen, aber ihr könnt auch natürlich auch Neues dazu packen. Und ich habe vor allen Dingen auch mal den Link zur Wikipedia Seite dazu.
Sehr gut. Wir haben bei Wikipedia, bei der deutschen Wikipedia, gibt es den Begriff Chaosradio. Da könnt ihr nach suchen. Und dann kommt ihr auf eine Seite. Da hangelt ihr euch noch zur Sendung 99 durch. Und das ist unsere Vorbereitungsseite für die Sendung. Da haben wir also alles, was wir so zusammengetragen haben oder vieles, was wir zusammengetragen haben, wie die Sendung ist da eingestellt. Und da gibt es auch schon eine recht lange Liste mit Fragen. Wovon zum Beispiel eine ist, wie sieht das eigentlich aus mit Unis sind. Unis auch, die Rechenzentren der Unis, wo ihr vielleicht auch eure E-Mail-Accounts habt, wenn ihr studiert oder da arbeitet, müssen ja eigentlich auch solche Überwachungsschnittstellen haben und auch Daten an die Behörden liefern. Wie siehts da aus, Jörg?
Ja, da muss ich jetzt leider sagen, das ist eine schwierige Frage. Das kommt immer darauf an, wie man das definiert. Habe ich mich jetzt so im Einzelnen nicht mit beschäftigt, aber wenn die Uni als Öffentlichkeit definiert wird, also die Studenten als Öffentlichkeit, dann müsste sie das theoretisch tun, aber das ist jetzt ohne Gewähr.
Wie ist das bei einer LAN-Party zum Beispiel, wenn ich sowas mache?
Gesetzt dem Fall, ich habe mehr als 1000 Teilnehmer in meiner LAN-Party. Gibt's ja. Ja, dann und biete denen einen E-Mail-Service an oder irgendwas in der Art was.
Oder Internetzugang.
Oder Internetzugang. Dann muss ich theoretisch der Direkt-TP das anzeigen, also der Regulierungsbehörde das anzeigen, dass ich so ein Telekommunikationsdienst aufbaue. Das wäre dann ein Feldversuch oder sowas. Und dann muss auch die Überwachung möglich sein.
Also ganz kurz mal, weil das ist was, was mich heute Abend auch schon mehrfach verwirrt hat, wo ich ja das Gefühl habe, dass sich die Gesetzgeber da selber noch nicht so ganz klar sind. Wir reden ja hier größtenteils über Verbindungen. Wir reden über Kommunikation zwischen Leuten. So, also wenn ich eine Lahnparty aufbaue, dann findet da natürlich Datenverkehr statt, innerhalb natürlich eines internen Netzwerkes. Aber es findet Kommunikation statt. Ist die Frage, muss es Kommunikation mit der Außenwelt sein? Oder reicht die Kommunikation von diesen 1000 Leuten untereinander? Also Filesharing ist zum Beispiel ein bekanntes Ding auf Lahnpartys, dass einfach alle Leute, die da sowieso zocken, zwischendurch so ein paar Files hin und her schieben, was natürlich auch gerne mal in das Auge der Fahnder irgendwie gekommen ist. Oder was ich auch vorhin im Kopf hatte, was mich sehr interessiert ist, wir reden hier nur von Verbindungen, die irgendwie ein Service Provider anbietet. Wenn ein Service Provider Verschlüsselung anbietet, dann muss er dann auch für die Männer in grün bereitstellen, die nicht verschlüsselte Variante. Wenn wir aber eine kleinen Software haben, die ja im Grunde auch für Kommunikation zuständig ist, und die läuft auf meinem eigenen Rechner, dann ist das wieder nicht der Fall. Also wo ist da die Grenze?
Na, das ist ganz einfach die Grenze. Also Verschlüsselung ist in Deutschland legal. Du darfst verschlüsseln. Du kannst das machen. In anderen Ländern ist das verboten.
Kann ja auch niemand vorschreiben, wie du verschlüsselst, mit welchem Schlüssel. Und es darf dir auch niemand vorgeben, dass du einen Nachschlüssel quasi irgendwo hinterlegen musst. Das ist in Deutschland zumindest nicht der Fall derzeit.
Aber man muss ganz ehrlich sagen, dass wenn ich dann verschlüsselne, weil es dann auch wieder so ungewöhnlich ist, dann denken die Leute doch wahrscheinlich, obwohl es in Deutschland so gang und gäbe sein könnte, dass ich doch wieder was auf dem Kerbholz habe eigentlich.
Ja, das ist auch eine interessante Frage, ob man sich verdächtig macht. Ich denke, da werden wir auch noch mal in einer späteren Runde darauf eingehen.
Richtig, ja. Zu denen, die jetzt davon, wir sprachen ja immer von Internetprovider in der Vergangenheit. Also das Gesetz differenziert da nicht, wer das jetzt ist. Ja, also das muss nicht zum Geschäftszweck sein. Man muss da kein Geld dafür verlangen. Das muss nicht irgendwie geschäftstätig sein. Also da gibt es überhaupt keine, keine Eingrenzung. Ja, also wenn ich jetzt privat einen Rechner betreibe und dort mehr als 1000 E-Mail-Accounts drauf hab, dann fall ich da drunter und muss so eine Schnittstelle anbieten. Selbst wenn es bloß irgendwie, was weiß ich, lauter Leute sind, die mir mal über den Weg gelaufen sind und denen ich aus reiner Menschenfreude irgendwie kostenlosen E-Mail-Account geben möchte.
Aber diese Zahl 1000, wo kommt die denn her? Weil ich meine, eine Organisation, die irgendwie was Illegales machen will, die hat in der Regel wahrscheinlich keine 1000 Mitglieder. Also wenn die irgendwie ihren Server da aufsetzen, da sind 28 Leute drauf, die sind aber total wichtig, dann wollen die doch eigentlich gerade da dran, an diese kleine Zelle sozusagen. Ist doch eigentlich Kratschtausend Leute oder nicht?
Nee, aber 1000 definiert in dem Bereich dann Öffentlichkeit. Also wo die 1000 jetzt genau herkommen, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, aber unter 1000 geht man halt davon aus, dass es nicht Öffentlichkeit in dem Sinne. Und die Abgrenzung ist einfach die verpflichtet, ist derjenige, der eine Telekommunikationsanlage betreibt, das kann auch ein Mail-Server sein, mit der Telekommunikationsdienste für die Öffentlichkeit angeboten werden. Und damit man einfach auch die Zahl ein bisschen reduzieren kann, wurde einfach eine Grenze gesetzt und das sind halt 1000. Man hätte auch 500 sagen können oder 100, aber dann würde natürlich die Zahl der Leute, die da drunter fallen, exponentiell wachsen und das ist auch gar nicht mehr nachzuhalten dann irgendwo. Also das steigt, das stößt das Ganze dann auch an organisatorische Grenzen.
Wir haben hier überhaupt keine organisatorischen Grenzen. Wir können so viele Leute ans Telefon kriegen, wie wir denn wollen, unter anderem euch, unter 0331 77 97 110 und am Telefon ist der René, namens René, aus Berlin.
Ja, ich würde gerne wissen, was mit der Weiterverwertung der Daten geschieht. Insbesondere, ob es vielleicht möglich ist, ein fiktives Szenario. Ich bin, keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall in Demos fotografiert worden, wurde als Mitglied einer kriminellen Organisation identifiziert. Mein E-Mail-Verkehr wird daraufhin abgehört oder es wird angeordnet. Und ja, weiß nicht, irgendein Verstoß gegen das Betragungsmittelgesetz kommt dadurch heraus von meiner Seite. Ist es möglich von der Polizei mich deshalb, also aufgrund des E-Mail-Verkehrs, dann den Prozess zu machen?
Das ist die Frage nach der Verwertbarkeit von solchen Sachen.
Das ist Strafprozessordnung. Da ist es halt, da kenne ich mich jetzt auch nicht so genau aus.
Also wir haben hier keine Juristen im Studio, dann müsstest du den Anwalt fragen. Aber ich glaube, dass es tatsächlich, wenn es völlig unabhängige Dinge sind, die miteinander nichts zu tun haben, dann darf das nicht verwertet werden.
Wobei ich mich da im Zweifelsfall denn auch nicht drauf verlassen würde.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Also es ist nicht bei uns, was ich definitiv weiß, es ist bei uns nicht so wie in den USA, so von wegen im Falle einer, wir haben eine falsche Tasche aufgemacht, deshalb geht der ganze Mensch frei. Also ganz so weit wird es bei uns nicht ausgelegt. Also im Ernstfall, wenn jemand eine Straftat begangen hat und der Staatsanwalt hat einen Beweis dafür, dann kann er auch anklagen. Also das ist die Geschichte. Da wird es keine Diskussion mehr geben.
Unabhängig von dem Link, also sagen wir mal, unabhängig davon, dass der die falsche Tasche aufgemacht hat und hoi hoi, da ist auf einmal viel Gras drin, gilt das dieser E-Mail als Beweis? Oder die werden dann auch wahrscheinlich schon gucken, dass sie irgendwie eine Übergabe von dir fotografieren können oder dich dabei erwischen in dem Akt sozusagen, der Straftat?
Ja, geh ich auch mal davon aus. Aber wie gesagt, wir sind alles keine Juristen, da können wir nicht sein. Wir können jetzt über die technische und über die ethische und was weiß ich was Komponente, aber über die tatsächlich juristische, gesetzgeberische, was auch immer Komponente da ist.
Vielleicht noch mal eine Frage, und zwar inwieweit gibt es da schon Auswertungen, also zum Beispiel beim großen Lauschangriff, wie viel Prozent Verbrecher wurden über abgehörte Telefonate gefasst?
Da gibt es eine Studie zu.
Das ist die Max-Planck-Studie, ja. Also es gibt eine Max-Planck-Studie zur Realität und Effizienz von Telefonüberwachungen. Und die haben sich mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt, wobei die auch in dieser Studie selber zugeben, dass es natürlich sehr schwer ist, einen Kausalzusammenhang zwischen Abhörungen und Verurteilungen und Abhörungen und erfolgreicher Strafverfolgung herzustellen. Aber diese Studie, wie vorher im Programm schon mal gesagt, zeichnet teilweise ein sehr trauriges Bild dieser ganzen Geschichte. Und es ist zwar nicht völlig traurig, aber es hat doch in manchen Teilbereichen ist die Effizienz nicht besonders hoch, aus verschiedensten Gründen. Aber diese Studie liest sich eigentlich ganz gut.
Wo kann ich die finden?
Ich bin gerade dabei, das ins Wikipedia auf die Seite einzustellen. Schau gleich mal vorbei in drei Minuten.
Und noch ein Letzte.
Gibt es eventuell auch so eine Mitteilungspflicht, wie beim großen Lauschangriff mit Telefonen? Da gab es ja, wenn man irgendwie nicht Teilnehmer war oder wenn man außersehen abgehört wurde, dann gab es eine Entschuldigungssicht der Behörden.
Ja, es gibt in dem 101 STPO eigentlich eine Regelung, wo drin steht, dass wenn das nicht die Ermittlung gefährdet und wenn es sonst keine Gründe dagegen gibt, muss es eigentlich mitgeteilt werden. Aber es ist ein Ergebnis dieser Max-Blank-Studie, dass in 71 Prozent der Fälle, dass den Beteiligten, also den Leuten, die abgehört wurden, nicht mitgeteilt wurde. Und wenn es dann zum Strafverfahren kommt, dann ist es natürlich wiederum so, da kann der Verteidiger sich diese Sachen angucken, wenn da irgendwas passiert.
Wir können ja mal so eine Stichprobe machen. Vielleicht könnte mal jemand anrufen. Also hier im Studio ist wahrscheinlich noch nie jemand informiert worden, dass irgendwie im Rahmen von irgendeiner Geschichte abgehört worden ist, oder? Guckt natürlich wieder keiner hoch, reagiert wieder keiner akustisch.
Ja, weil es was mit den Streams ist, was schief gelaufen ist, da musste ich mich jetzt irgendwie gerade was abblechen lassen.
Ich bin gerade dabei, den Max-Blank-Legalität.
Wiederhol doch mal die Frage.
Ich wollte nur fragen, ob irgendeiner von uns schon mal so eine Benachrichtigung bekommen hat. Also bei mir ist es nicht der Fall.
Nein. Das Einzige, was ich mal bekommen habe, wo ich schon überrascht war, dass mir irgendjemand mitgeteilt hat, dass sie überhaupt irgendwelche Daten über mich gespeichert hat, da war ich doch angenehm überrascht. Das war mal, glaube ich, der Polizeipräsident in Berlin, der mir das mal mitgeteilt hatte.
Was hat er dir mitgeteilt?
Dass sie die Daten über mich gespeichert haben, aber ich dann mir keine Sorgen machen, ist das alles okay, es wird auch nicht gegen mich ermittelt und so was, sondern einfach nur irgendwie im Rahmen von, keine Ahnung, Zeugen, Aussagen, irgendwas, lalalala.
Also wenn irgendeiner von euch schon mal diese Art von Mitteilung erhalten hat, dass er im Rahmen irgendeiner Aperaaktion mit dabei war, dann ruft er doch mal an, bitte. 0331 77 97 1 1 0, das würde uns doch interessieren. Vielleicht auch wie so ein kleiner Briefbogen ausschaut. Guck mal immer gerne mal mit rein. René, dank dir für den Anruf. So, und der Richard aus Görlitz ist dran. Hallo Richard.
Und zwar wollte ich fragen, wie das im Allgemeinen geregelt ist mit der Kompetenz von Entscheidungsträgern, die jetzt beurteilen, ob eine E-Mail jetzt als preis oder nicht preis verwendet werden kann. Weil das ist ja nun doch ein diffiziles Thema. Das sind elektronisch erstellte Daten, das heißt, ich kann die auf meinem Rechner einfach nacherzeugen. Und das recht, wenn die nie verschüttet sind und keine Identität ist, ist das absolut bestätigt. Sozusagen, schlimmstes Beispiel, ich habe einen Freund, ich weiß, dass der abgehört wird, ich hack seinen E-Mail-Account und schreibe da rein, E-Mail-Verkehr, dass er mit bin Laden Anschlag auf das World Trade Center in Dresden plant. Wie kann das ausgewertet werden?
Wahrscheinlich reicht das schon, wenn du ihm einfach so eine E-Mail schickst von einem gefakten Hotmail-Account, um ihn da echt in Schwierigkeiten zu bringen.
Aber das ist doch nun mal, wenn man jetzt mal das deutsche Recht betrachtet, solange unschuldig bis ihm die Schuld nicht bewiesen ist, ist das ja nun definitiv mal kein Beweis. Also ich bin nebenbei in meiner Hochschule Systemadministrator und hab mich da auf ein bisschen mit auseinanderzusetzen, was ich mir speichern darf und was nicht. Und da hab ich mir jetzt auch mal letztens überlegt, wie sieht das aus? Ich schreib da fein in meine Logfiles, aber ich meine, ohne weiteres kann ich da jemanden Gigabyte draufaddieren. Ja, und das würde niemandem auffallen. Also inwieweit sind solche mehr oder elektronisch gespeicherten Daten dann aussagekräftig und welche kompetente oder hoffentlich kompetente Personen schätzt das dann ein?
Das ist eine Frage und vielleicht auch ein sehr guter Hinweis an den Strafverteidiger eigentlich, wie man die Beweiskraft von solchen Daten erschüttern kann. Also weil es ist natürlich schwer nachzuweisen, rein technisch, dass die E-Mail tatsächlich von demjenigen versendet wurde, als der oben im Header steht. Das ist natürlich klar. Also anders als bei einer Sprachüberwachung, wo ich dann irgendwie ein Sprachprofil machen kann oder sowas und nachweisen kann, das ist die Person, ist es bei einer E-Mail recht schwierig. Da wird es dann auch so sein, dass dann der Provider angehört wird, also als Zeuge mehr oder minder und dann sagen, dass er darstellen muss, dass diese E-Mail tatsächlich so zustande gekommen ist und von seinem selber verschickt wurde. Aber er kann natürlich auch nicht bestätigen, weil er hat ja keine Kamera auf dem Rechner des Versenders.
Aber dem Service Provider obliegt natürlich eigentlich die primäre Überwachung. Das heißt, die Behörden geben einem Nicht-Profi in dem Bereich in die Hand, dass der das quasi richtig anschließt. Klar, irgendwie ist da der Anschluss, aber deren Werkzeuge werden ja dafür benutzt. Das heißt, es ist eigentlich jemand, der überhaupt nicht das machen dürfte, im Grunde, oder? Also das ist wieder was, wo man auch im Grunde...
Die eingesetzte Software und die eingesetzte Technologie für die Überwachung, die muss ja von der Regulierungsbehörde auch zumindest nach dem derzeitigen Stand der Telekommunikations- und Überwachungsverordnung genehmigt werden. Ja, das heißt, ich kann da jetzt nicht... Also ich kann schon mir da Software selber schreiben und zusammen instricken oder was auch immer, aber dann muss ich die halt zertifizieren oder genehmigen lassen von der Regulierungsbehörde, dass die auch tatsächlich das irgendwie ordnungsgemäß protokolliert und kopiert und was auch immer.
Aber ich dachte, dass der Punkt, wo das Ganze abgenommen wird, im Grunde da startet, Blackbox-mäßig, dass ich bitte so und so die Daten zu liefern habe und mit welcher, mit wie ich diesen Datenstrom liefere, ist doch eigentlich Schnuppe, oder nicht?
Nein, nein, es gibt eine Abnahme des Gesamtsystems. Und zwar der Software, der Hardware und der Organisation. Also alles. Also auch der Vorhaltung, die ich organisatorisch treffe, um das entgegenzunehmen und umzusetzen. Und es ist aber trotzdem so, ich kann auch als Provider natürlich nie sagen, dass eine E-Mail, wo heinsmustermann.meinemaildomain.de draufsteht, auch wirklich von Heinz Mustermann verschickt wurde. Den letzten Beweis kann ich nie antreten. Anders als bei einer Sprachüberwachung zum Beispiel.
Aber letztendlich geht es auch in seltenen Fällen tatsächlich nur um Beweisbarkeit vor Gericht, sondern es geht darum, die Ermittlung zu unterstützen. Das heißt also, um diese Netzwerke, die Verbindung unter Leuten untereinander aufzuzeigen.
Und es ist auch so, wenn man sich mit Strafverfolgungsbehörden unterhält, für die ist es auch immer nur ein Baustein in ihrem Ermittlungsverfahren. Also da kommt dann auch sicherlich, wenn es einen konkreteren Tatverdacht gibt, eine Hausdurchsuchung etc. um wirklich konkrete Beweise oder den berühmten rauchenden Colt dann in der Hand zu finden. Also nur auf Telekommunikationsüberwachung. Das wird dann höchstens ergänzend hinzugezogen. Also da glaube ich nicht. Also gerade bei E-Mail.
Da kommen wir doch zur nächsten Frage. Ich meine, inwieweit reicht dann so ein elektronisches Intit dazu aus, jemanden eine Hausdurchsuchung zu machen? Also das sind ja nur eindeutig eingeschränkte Grundrechte, die da raus entstehen, weil mein Haus ist mein Haus und da hat keiner seine Nase reinzustecken. Das ist im Gesetz so verankert. Und jetzt häcke ich einen Account von einem Kumpel und schreibe da rein, er hat so einen Laden hier Kontakt und bla und blub. Also das ist ein ganz einfaches Beispiel. Und dann kommen sie zu ihm nach Hause und durchsuchen erstmal seine Brüder. Also das kann ja irgendwo nicht angehen.
Das Problem dabei ist, wenn sie dann das Kilogramm im Kühlschrank finden, dann hilft dir das auch nichts mehr, dass das möglicherweise rechtswidrig war.
Ja, also ich meine, gut, ich hab kein Kilogramm im Kühlschrank.
Aber du bist ja voll davon ausgegangen, dass dein Freund quasi schon überwacht wird. Du weißt das und dann schiebst du ihm quasi nochmal das Extra-Ticket unter. Das war ja die Prämisse.
Ja, na gut, ich kann aber auch dafür sorgen, dass er überwacht wird. Also das ist ja nur kein Problem, weil jemanden unter Verdacht zu stellen, wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, dass nicht nur Deutschland die Internetverbindungen verfolgt, sondern auch gewisse andere Institutionen, dann kann man da schon von ausgehen, dass man das irgendwie, wenn man sich wirklich langjährig damit beschäftigt, wieder hinkriegen würde.
Also Tatsache ist, dass es auf jeden Fall einfacher ist, zum Beispiel jemand irgendwelche E-Mails unterzuschieben oder so, als irgendwie an einem Tatort irgendwie fremde Fingerabdrücke zu hinterlassen.
Ja, ja, das ist auf jeden Fall. Aber ich sehe das auch ein bisschen so, gerade wenn es jetzt um Speicherung von Verbindungsdaten geht oder von allgemeinen Datenströmen beim Provider jetzt auch Problematik Fishearing. Das ist selbst für mich auch nur das gleiche Thema. Weil ich sehe das halt von der technischen Seite her, ob das nur um E-Mails geht oder ob das nur um FDP-Datenströme geht. Das ist ja im Prinzip egal. Der Verdacht, dass jemand irgendwas zieht, entsteht ja dadurch, dass beim Provider angefragt wird, wie viel Traffic jetzt zum Beispiel im Monat bei dem und dem anfällt. Dann ist ja der Verdacht schon durchaus bestätigt, dass derjenige Fishearing betreibt.
Nicht so wie bei den Stromzählern, wenn jemand einen hohen Stromverbrauch hat, dass dann da die angenommen wird, dass er die dicken Natriumlampen zu Hause hat.
Also wir werden ja auch sehr spekulativ jetzt. Also das sind Sachen, da gibt es tausend und einen Einzelfall, sicherlich wie so ein Ermittlungsverfahren läuft. Also Fakt ist, obwohl das Bankinstitut ja auch richtig sagt, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu einfach, aber ganz so einfach ist es nur auch nicht. Ich muss zu einem Richter gehen und muss dem sagen, ich hab hier einen konkreten Tatverdacht. Und dann muss ich mir was aufschreiben, worin dieser konkrete Tatverdacht besteht, sonst kriege ich auch keine Anordnung. Diese Hürde gibt es immer noch. Also das ist so, ganz so einfach ist es auch nicht. Und dann muss man ja auch sehen, wenn so eine Überwachungsmaßnahme angeordnet wird, dann gucken die sich ja nicht eine E-Mail an und sagen dann, hey bin Laden, super. Sondern wenn man sich auch mal in die Max-Planck-Studie reinguckt, wie lange solche Überwachungsmaßnahmen teilweise laufen. Also sie dürfen laufen bis drei Monate und dürfen dann jeweils um drei Monate verlängert werden. Dann geht das teilweise über Wochen hinweg, wo Kommunikationsbeziehungen etc. ausgewertet werden. Also das müsste man dann in dem Fall, das ist aber auch wieder rein spekulativ, schon sehr systematisch tun. Also über längere Zeiträume hinweg den anderen belasten.
Ja, und gerade bei terroristischen Vereinigungen ist es wichtig, die Netzwerke aufzudecken, da werden die einen Teufel tun und einen, der eine Mail bekommen hat, irgendwie Hobbs zu nehmen. Die wollen ja wissen, mit wem hat der zu tun. Das haben wir ja auch schon mehrfach gesagt. Ja, das war halt ein dummes Beispiel jetzt.
Gegenbeispiel ist ja auch bei jedem Anschlag und bei allem, was passiert, gibt es immer Dutzende von Drittbreitfahrern, die einfach irgendwo in der Zeitung stehen wollen und es im Hörer greifen und anrufen und sagen, ich war es. Oder ich kenn den, der es war.
Im Zweifelsfall hast du Spam in einer E-Mail, in der drin steht, ob du kleine Mädchen kaufen möchtest. So, da wird die Polizei auch nicht sagen, oh, der will kleine Mädchen kaufen, nur weil das jetzt Spam ist. Davon gibt es so viel, das müssen die schon irgendwie handeln.
Ganz kurz nochmal zurück auf die Aussage, wir haben hier begrafen, elektronischen Beweismitteln. Inwiefern sind die aussagekräftig, oder sind die nichts sagen?
Da sind wir die falschen Ansprechpartner, muss ich irgendwie ganz klar sagen. Wir sind hier keine Anwälte, keine Staatsanwälte, keine Ermittlungsbeamten, die mit sowas täglich zu tun haben oder die da Erfahrung hätten.
Also von der technischen Seite kann man sagen, man kann natürlich eine E-Mail und ASCII verändern, also das ist klar, da gibt es auch gar keinen Nachweis.
Man kann jedes Logfile verändern, das ist alles überhaupt kein Thema. Aber das hab ich auch schon bei Faxen oder bei sonst was. Bei gescannten Dokumenten ist überall, das ist so eine generische Frage. Ich denke, wir sollten uns wieder auf unser eigenes Thema konzentrieren.
Genau, wir schweifen wieder ab. Danke für den Anruf. Die letzte Stunde ist angebrochen im Blue Moon Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club heute Abend. Wenn ihr eingeschaltet habt, dann werdet ihr festgestellt haben, sehr technisches Thema, trotzdem ethische Belange und heute bitte weniger juristische Belange. Wir sind da in dem Punkt nicht so firm, können ja nicht immer unseren ganzen Tross an Anwälten dabei haben, den wir natürlich besitzen. Wir besitzen ganz viele Anwälte. Der Harald, der Frank im Studio vom Chaos Computer Club, Jörg, unser Gast, IT-Berater und meine Person, der Malotky. 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer und ihr könnt weiter anrufen, wenn ihr was sagen möchtet. Thema heute großer Lauschangriff bzw. der größere. E-Mail und Co sind jetzt auch mit dabei, elektronische Kommunikation wird überwacht. Was haltet ihr davon? 0331 77 97 110. Auf eins der elektronische Musik, drunter machen wir es nicht. Hier ist das Chaosradio auf Fritz. Thema heute Abend, Lauschangriff auf die elektronische Art. Seit diesem Jahr, also seit 1.1.2005, werden E-Mail und andere Wege der elektronischen Kommunikation mit abgehört. Was haltet ihr davon? 031 77 97 110. Da könnt ihr eure Meinung loswerden und mit uns diskutieren. Auch wenn ihr Fragen habt, technischer Art, dann sind wir genau die richtigen Ansprechpartner für euch, denn es betrifft sowohl die User, die also quasi ihre E-Mails schreiben, wenn ihr irgendwie eine mal geschickt habt. Ich nehme mal an, das war bei fast jedem der Fall. Dann kann das jetzt gelesen werden, ob euch das stört. Und dann gibt es natürlich die Möglichkeit, dass ihr irgendwie über diese magische Grenze kommt und mehr als 1000 Leuten irgendwelche Dienste anbietet. Dann seid ihr nämlich gefragt und müsst den Behörden im Zweifelsfall, eigentlich nicht nur im Zweifelsfall, sondern generell den Zugang zur Verfügung stellen, genau zu euren Datenbanken und Ähnlichem und zu eurem Verkehr, wenn die das denn wollen. Also jetzt zu dem Datenverkehr, ne? Am Telefon ist die Morena, Name ist Morena.
So halte ich mehrere Fragen. Angefangen würde ich mal fragen, ich bin derzeit bei Yahoo und wollte fragen, ob es für mich Sinn macht, mir einen E-Mail-Anbieter in der Schweiz oder über das Google-Gmail zu suchen, ob sie sicherer sind oder nicht abgezapft werden können.
Na, also Abhörgesetzgebung gibt es natürlich in vielen Ländern. Das ist nur die Frage, ob dann irgendwie eine Amtshilfe international zustande kommt zwischen der deutschen Behörde und der ausländischen Behörde. Aber ich würde sagen, wenn man es darauf anlegt, dann sollte man sich einen E-Mail-Anbieter im Ausland suchen, der keine Niederlassung in Deutschland hat, der also hier nicht irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen, den man hier nicht dran kriegen kann in Deutschland.
Und in einem möglichst sehr exotischen Staat angesiedelt ist.
Genau. Irgendwo ein Land, in dem es unwahrscheinlich ist, dass sie mit ihrer Gesetzgebung und überhaupt mit der Technologie und mit allem so weit sind, dass sie schon über solche Überwachungsschnittstellen und Maßnahmen nachdenken. Na ja, die USA sind noch nicht gerade dafür bekannt, dass sie irgendwie eine besonders viel Wert auf Privatsphäre legen. Bei Google ist es ja noch genau umgekehrt. Gmail durchsucht ja sogar noch selber die ganzen E-Mails nach Schlüsselwörtern. Du gibst ihnen dadurch, dass du die Geschäftsbedingungen akzeptierst, die erlaubt ist dazu, das zu analysieren, was in den E-Mails drin steht. Also das halte ich da doch für strategisch eher ungeschickt.
Außerdem, wenn du das Ganze über deinen Account abrufst, also wenn du zu Hause dann mit DSL drin bist, dann können sie dich ja über deinen DSL Zugang kriegen und lesen das sowieso.
Ja, aber du kannst die gängigen E-Mail-Propagode wie POP3 oder IMAP oder auch bei Webmail, kannst du alles über SSL oder TLS und dann sich das verschlüsseln. Und wenn dann tatsächlich die Gegenstelle nicht irgendwie unter die deutsche Rechtsprechung fällt, dann hast du da schon, müsste ich sagen, einen gewissen Bonus.
Aber wisst ihr das, wenn jetzt Google, die haben mit Sicherheit doch irgendwie eine Vertretung im Büro in Deutschland, dann wird sich die Anordnung gegen die richten und die müssen das entsprechend auch wieder international umsetzen, weil sich wahrscheinlich die Staatsanwaltschaften direkt dafür interessiert, wo jetzt die Server wirklich stehen. Die sagen Deutschland, Büro hier, zack, umsetzen.
Wenn ein Anbieter, dessen Server auch im Ausland steht, eine Niederlassung in Deutschland hat, dann richtet sich die Anordnung gegen die Niederlassung in Deutschland und die muss gucken, dass sie so umsetzen kann.
Da hätte ich eine andere Frage. Wenn ich jetzt sage, ich möchte Daten gelöscht haben von meinem E-Mail-Anbieter oder von meinem Provider, muss er die löschen oder muss er die aufbewahren? Inwiefern kann ich da selber entscheiden, was dann gelöscht wird oder wenn ich da nicht mehr bin oder irgendwas kündige? Inwiefern müssen wir das aufbewahren, was irgendwann mal verwendet werden kann?
Also da gibt es mehrere Regelungen. Bei deinen Adressdaten, Bestandsdaten sozusagen, da ist es so, die müssen ein Jahr nach der Kündigung des Vertrages gelöscht werden. Andere Daten, also wie zum Beispiel Verbindungsdaten deiner E-Mail, irgendwelche Routerlogs oder solche Geschichten, die dürfen gar nicht aufgehoben werden. Und es ist sogar, in der Literatur wird es sogar vertreten, dass es eigentlich nicht erlaubt ist, die dynamische Zuordnung von IP-Adressen zu speichern. Selbst die müssen, sobald die dynamische IP-Adresse nicht mehr gebraucht wird, um die Verbindung herzustellen, eigentlich gelöscht werden.
Aber die Logs werden noch in der Praxis aufbewahrt, oder?
Die Praxis und die Theorie sind zwei verschiedene Dinge.
Na ja, das ist insofern schwierig, also Internetprovider ist es insofern schwierig, als du musst ja erstmal dich per Telefon irgendwo einwählen oder per DSL. Und dann ist dieser Anschluss ja schon mal in Deutschland.
Und es ist auch so, in der Europäischen Union macht das wenig Sinn. In der Schweiz, die Schweiz ist nach allem, was ich weiß, sogar noch strenger mit ihren Überwachungsregeln als wir.
Ich habe mal zuvor jemand was gesagt, ob schon jemand vor hat zu klagen oder was auch immer. Und das, was jetzt eigentlich verabschiedet wurde als Gesetz, verstößt er eigentlich gegen das Grundgesetz. Denn Artikel 10 Absatz 1 sagt er, dass Briefgeheimnisse wie postile Kommunikation und Zahlmeldung sind unverletzlich.
Es sei denn, es gibt Gesetze, die das einschränken.
Bis zum Ende lesen.
Und es ist auch so, es hat sich rechtlich, also vom Gesetz her zum 1. Januar nichts geändert. Also diese Regelung, die da umgesetzt wurde, da ist einfach nur die Frist ausgelaufen, bis zu der das umgesetzt werden musste. Die Regelung selber ist, soweit ich weiß, aus Mitte 2003. Also das ist aber auch nur der technische Standard, nicht das Gesetz, was dem zu Grunde liegt.
Ja, aber eigentlich ist es schade, dass wieder mit anderen Gesetzen Grundgesetze ausgehebelt werden. Also, dann brauchst du sie auch nicht geben. Ist ja auch schwach, wenn ich dann...
Na ja, also, natürlich, sicherlich, du kannst dich irgendwann auf den Punkt stellen, das Grundgesetz kann auch geändert werden. Ja, also, brauch ich kein Grundgesetz, weil die Legislative kann das Grundgesetz ja ändern, wenn die entsprechenden Mehrheiten da sind. Es ist halt immer die Frage, wie viel, wie soll ich sagen, wie viel Glauben hab ich in irgendeinem derartiges System und wie viel Vertrauen hab ich darauf und wie viel moralische oder ethische Skrupel haben die entsprechenden Vertreter in der Legislative, das entsprechend, ja, dann doch die Grundzüge aufrechtzuerhalten. Und wenn tatsächlich mal die Verfassung zu weit eingeschränkt wird, dann gibt es ja das Verfassungsgericht, was sich darum kümmern soll, sofern es angerufen wird.
Okay, alles klar, das war's dann schon mal, Frank.
Danke, Morena. Der Dennis ist am Telefon. Hallo, Dennis.
Ja, guten Abend. Ich wollte immer auch was dazu sagen. Ich mein, ich find's gut. Ich finde, es sollte ausgerichtet werden. Denn ich finde einfach, die Überwachung muss stattfinden, da das Internet ziemlich viele Möglichkeiten bietet, unter anderem irgendwelche Videos oder anderes in Umlauf zu bringen. Als bestes Beispiel, ein Kamerad von mir kam letztens an und meinte, ja, er hat sich ur die geilen Videos auf Handy gezogen von wegen irgendeinen Typ, den sie abgeschlachtet haben, Kehle durchgeschnitten und so. Oder ein älterer Mann, der mit einer 7-Jährigen im Bett liegt und so.
Ich mein, sowas will keiner sehen.
Und ich finde sowas gehört einfach nicht in Internet. Und sobald man den Leuten die Möglichkeit bietet, es zu veröffentlichen und damit Geld zu machen, so fördert man das. Und jeder, der jetzt gerade angerufen hat und meinte, dass er was dagegen hat, sollte einfach mal drüber nachdenken, wenn er selbst Kinder hätte, ob er wollte, dass irgendwelche Leute damit Geld machen wollen und die Kinder entführen und irgendwelche Sachen mit denen machen und dann Internet stellen. Nur um da profitieren zu wollen.
Ja, das Internet bringt uns ja doch auch einiges an andere Möglichkeiten außer diesen Dingen. Es ist halt eine Abwägung, wie bei allen Dingen.
Ja, das ist klar. Aber ich meine, wenn ich nichts Schlimmes vor hab, beziehungsweise nichts dir selbst zu zwiederehlt, dann brauch ich gar keine Angst haben. Ich meine, wenn ich meine jenseits normalen Sachen hab, ich meine, die Polizei interessiert sich bestimmt nicht davon, dazu, was ich jetzt mit meiner Freundin schreibe, ob ich nur meine, dass ich mit ihr ins Bett steigen will oder sonst was, dann geht denen im Endeffekt am Arsch vorbei. Aber ich finde, solche Leute sollten stärker bewacht werden.
Ja, die Frage ist halt nur, was ist mit Leuten, die in irgendeiner Art und Weise aktiv sind, was sind sich politische Aktivisten zum Beispiel, die durchaus im Rahmen des Legalen operieren. Ich möchte jetzt gar nicht mehr unterstellen, dass die irgendwas Illegales tun. Aber die einfach politisch in einer Weise aktiv sind, wie es vielleicht dem etablierten Staat nicht unbedingt so recht ist. Dann kommst du halt in den Konflikt hinein, wo du dann sagst, der Staat hat die Möglichkeit, das abzuhören. Er bekommt das alles mit, was da passiert. Und derjenige, der gerade die politische Macht im Land hat, kann dann die anderen irgendwie hier überwachen und unter Druck setzen.
Da muss man abwiegen, natürlich. Aber im Endeffekt hat nicht nur unsere Regierung gemacht. Ich meine, wenn unsere Regierung sagt, der ist politisch, der ist gegen uns, den wollen wir jetzt verknacken, da sind immer noch eine Menge andere Leute, die da mitzureden haben. Und das wird auch öffentlich, auf alle Fälle.
Na wer hat denn mitzureden, wenn bei uns der Innenminister irgendwie entscheidet, dass es jetzt irgendwie eine terroristische Vereinigung oder so?
Ich meine, wenn so was kommt, das wird öffentlich, auf alle Fälle. Das kann man nicht verbergen, irgendwo kommt es immer durch. Das wird in Zeitungen, das wird in der Presse veröffentlicht. Und wenn dann die Masse dagegen ist und die Masse sagt, ja, das ist einfach nur Willkür des Staates, weil die meinen, dass das dagegen ist, dann wird sich der Staat auch dementsprechend beugen oder abgewählt.
Das ist aber ein gesundes Weltbild. Also gesünder als die Gesellschaft in Wirklichkeit ist. Also die Leute, die sich für diese Sachen interessieren, man merkt ja selber, wenn man jetzt hier die ganze Sendung verfolgt hat, wie schwierig dieses Thema ist. Also es ist ja nicht unbedingt, was man jetzt an erster Stelle genießt und wo man sich so denkt, wow, da kann ich mich aber berieseln lassen. Das ist ja jetzt Boulevard pur. Sondern es ist halt ziemlich schwierig zu greifen. Und die meisten Leute interessieren sich ab der dritten Minute kein Stück mehr dafür, weil sie einfach keinen Bock haben, sich anzustrengen oder weil es einfach schwierig ist. Und ich glaube, das sind genau diese Sachen.
Klar, irgendwo ist es richtig. Aber andererseits, ich finde es nicht gut, dass einfach solche Sachen frei abrufbar sind. Und ich finde, solche Leute, die sowas im Internet stellen sollen, einfach verfolgt und bestraft.
Im Grunde ist es ein anderer Schuh, wenn man so möchte. Weil da geht es darum, dass bestimmte Internetinhalte angeboten werden und nicht, dass da quasi die Kommunikation grundsätzlich verfolgt wird. Der Typ, der das macht, also grundsätzlich sind die meisten dieser Anbieter im Ausland. Da kannst du sowieso nichts machen. Und die werden sich auch über Telefon unterhalten. Dann kann man auf das Telefon abhören und so weiter. Also die ganzen alten Maßnahmen greifen daher auch.
Ja, und das heißt, es soll erweitert werden. Diese Leute müssen insgesamt auch die, die den Internet stellen. Die haben selbst Leute, die sich dafür interessieren. Und das ist eine Interessengemeinschaft, die sich findet. Auch wenn das nur 28 Leute sind, wie vorhin schon gesagt, sollen halt die 28 Leute überwacht werden.
Du kannst aber auch irgendwann anfangen, dass du sagst, irgendwelche Ladendetektive und alle möglichen Leute sollen wegen jeder Kleinigkeit überwacht werden. Und dann landen wir halt irgendwo, wo wir echt nicht landen wollen. Ja, es gibt ja diese Katalogstraftaten. Und das ist halt ein gesellschaftlicher Diskurs notwendig, was genau dieser Katalog alles umfassen soll. Das ist ja richtig. Wenn wir uns mal damit abfinden, dass es eben diese Ermittlungsmöglichkeiten geben soll.
Zum Beispiel mal ein anderes Beispiel. Du nimmst es jetzt nicht so wahr, weil du dich als guter Bürger wähnst. Aber du bist schon jemand, der sagt, ich hab jetzt nichts zu befürchten. Ich schreib meiner Freundin halt mal zwischendurch, würde dich gerne mal von hinten anfassen. Und das nehmen die jetzt ja nicht so ernst. Alles super. Aber ich hab mal eine Zeit lang in Frankreich verbracht, in Paris. Und da ist es einfach mal nur so ganz kleiner Unterschied. Hier läuft ein Polizist drum. Meistens alleine oder auch mal zu zweit. In Frankreich laufen Polizisten immer zu dritt rum. Und einer von diesen Polizisten hat immer ein Maschinengewehr. Und die Jungs sehen auch so ein bisschen aus wie eine Gang. Die sind ein bisschen martialischer angezogen. Und ich hab Geschichten gehört von Typen, der hat einen Kumpel von mir, hat irgendwie die Füße auf der Bank gegenüber gehabt in der U-Bahn. So, dann kommen da die Typen ran, sagen bitte den Fuß runter. Der sagt, der leckt mich doch am Arsch. Ja, kannst aber einen drauf lassen, da ziehen die den da erstmal raus. Und die sind da etwas gröber. Und da erschreckst du dich, wenn du auf einmal merkst, ok, rechtsstaatlich sieht das alles ein bisschen anders aus. Das sind immer Nuancen, aber genau darum geht's. Weil es geht ja um dein normales Menschenleben, das du führst.
Ich meine, wenn ich zu einem Polizisten sage, lege ich mich doch am Arsch. Ich meine, ein Polizist soll jemand sein, vor dem man Respekt hat. Wenn der was sagt, dann wird das schon richtig sein, meistens jedenfalls. Aber ich meine, der wird jetzt nicht aus reiner Willkür sagen, mach das nicht, besonders wenn er in der Gesellschaft von anderen ist.
Das ist aber auch nur ein Mensch, mit allen Schwächen.
Natürlich, aber wenn ich einen Polizisten beleidige, dann muss ich damit rechnen, dass da Gegenwehr kommt.
Moment, was heißt Gegenwehr?
Der muss mich nicht gleich zusammenschlagen. Aber ich finde eigentlich, die Polizei sollte schon ein bisschen Respekt vermitteln. Und wenn ich einfach so sagen kann, dass ich einen Polizisten lecke, der nichts machen darf und einfach weitergeht, dann habe ich keinen Respekt vor der Polizei.
Das ist natürlich jetzt eine andere Diskussion. Vielleicht hättet ihr das Beispiel auch nicht einbringen sollen, aber es geht darum, dass es kleine Unterschiede gibt und man sich immer überlegen muss, was will man haben und was nicht. Und wie sicher fühlt man sich dann und wie frei fühlt man sich vor allen Dingen noch?
Auf das Thema, was Sie angesprochen haben, wenn ich jetzt zu meiner Freundin schreibe, ja, ich fasse mich gerne von hinten an. Wenn sie mich überwachen, wenn sie mich hochnehmen, dann habe ich immer noch die Chance, dass ich meine Freundin wird sowieso dann dazu eingeladen und muss ihre Aussage machen. Und dementsprechend wird sich das dann auch aufklären. Wenn ich da nicht unrechtliche Macht habe, dann wird sich das aufklären und dementsprechend wird es auch weitergehen. Ich meine, das nehme ich gerne in Kauf, wenn ich dafür weiß, dass Leute, die wirklich Scheiße bauen, die wirklich irgendwelche Kinderfallwahl geben bzw. Leute umbringen, dass die dementsprechend verhaftet werden. Ich finde es nicht gut, dass sich jeder im Internet abrufen kann, wie da irgendjemand in die Kehle durchgeschnitten wird oder sonst. Oder wie ein 30-Jähriger mit einem 7-jährigen Sex hat.
Sagen wir es mal so, es ist natürlich nicht gut, dass das im Internet abgerufen werden kann, aber ich finde es schlimmer, dass jemand jemand anderem die Kehle durchschneidet. Also das ist die Straftat.
Ja, sowas muss verfolgt werden. Sowas muss einfach und ich finde, sowas gehört auch nicht im Internet. Aber das ist in der Zählung drin und das kann ich immer noch abrufen.
Einen abschließenden Kommentar. Wer bestimmt, wo die Grenzlinie ist zwischen dem, was der Standardbürger abzurufen hat oder was er abrufen darf und was nicht? Bei so einem Fall, den du beschreibst, ist es sicherlich relativ eindeutig.
Die Menschlichkeit. Einfach die Menschlichkeit. Alles, was gegen den freien Willen des Menschen ist, darf nicht abgerufen werden.
Aber guck mal, dann zeigt RTL, wir erinnern uns an den Vorfall, dass eine Schule in Russland, dass da die ganzen Schüler geiseln waren. Das ist natürlich ein sehr interessantes Thema für die Medien. Und dann zeigen die danach, wie irgendwelche 12-jährigen Mädchen barbrüstig, weil sie irgendwie von ihren terroristischen Peinigern ausgezogen worden sind, ins Freie laufen. Als Voyeurist hast du da auch deinen Spaß. Du sagst ja nicht, RTL muss dafür jetzt zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden. Also die Grenze ist schwer zu ziehen.
Klar, wir sind uns einig.
Hey, Kinderpornografie.
Ich meine, das Mädchen wird jetzt nicht gegen seinen Willen gezwungen worden sein, aus dem Gebäude rauszulaufen, ohne einen Oberteil. Ein anderes Thema ist, wenn ich jetzt ein Mädchen entführe, das ausziehe und dann vor der Kamerastelle und mit dem Obert anstelle oder einfach so vor der Kamerastelle.
Gut, also wir nehmen es einfach mal so mit, Dennis, weil das ist jetzt eine Diskussion, die können wir ziemlich lange führen, aber ich glaube, wir haben unsere Standpunkte klar gemacht. Dank dir für einen Anruf.
Okay, wiederhören.
So, der Kai aus Wolfshagen. Hallo Kai.
Und zwar habe ich schon mal so einen Zettel bekommen, dass ich abgehört wurde.
Ah, ich habe uns auch ein paar E-Mail bekommen, aber erzähl das mal.
Und hat dann auch ein paar Sachen, die dann nicht so dem Gesetz entsprechen.
Was war das denn so? Nur, damit wir mal wissen, wo wir uns gerade bewegen.
Was man mal früher gemacht hatte, deshalb man abgehört wurde. Naja, weiß ich gar nicht mehr so genau.
Also ich wurde dann selber abgehört.
Also ein Bekannter von mir.
Ah, und du warst sozusagen dann beteiligt dann?
Ja, und dann genau, da stand dann halt auch so drinnen die ganze Nummer. Also praktisch, eigentlich mein ganzer Telefon, wo sei ich mal, vom Handy. Haben die dann weiter, wurde mitverfolgt, aber wurde dann halt eingestellt und so. Und kam aber nach dem, also ich kannte dann auch den Inding. Also ich hab den Zettel erst bekommen, nachdem dann das Verfahren bei ihm dann lief.
Haben die dir den Sachverhalt dann auch erklärt, oder stand da einfach nur, sie sind im Rahmen einer Aktion abgehört worden, weil lalalalalala das und das gemacht hat, oder stand...
Ja, genau, ja so stand da drinnen ungefähr, also weil der und der halt das und das gemacht hat und in dem Rahmen. Und daraufhin wurde dann auch nochmal erklärt, dass dann die und die Nummern von mir aus genommen wurden und dann auch mit verfolgt wurden sozusagen. Aber mehr halt nicht.
Ja, wir haben übrigens auch eine Mail bekommen von jemand, der ist im Rahmen von Castor-Transport-Protesten sogar präventiv überwacht worden und ist dann freundlicherweise dann hinterher informiert worden. Er hat dann also ein Schreiben gekriegt, das war Niedersachsen und Harland des Niedersächsischen Polizeigesetzes. Präventiv wurde seine Daten erfasst und der quasi abgehört und ist dann entsprechend da auch darüber informiert worden. Also es gibt offensichtlich Fälle, wo es Informationen stattfinden. Das sind dann wahrscheinlich die, wir bleiben übrig, 28, 27 Prozent, die dann tatsächlich da noch informiert werden. Sehr wenig, ja.
Wir haben dich jetzt ja auch mit der Lupo gesucht.
Ja, eine Bekannte hat mir auch erzählt, die hat in so einer Telefongesellschaft gearbeitet und also eine ziemlich kleine, wartet, 98, gibt's gar nicht mehr, glaube ich. Und die hat dann auch mal erzählt, dass diese Angst war, wurde nicht abgehört damals und nur im Rahmen der Ermittlungen und so, aber ich sag mal, die hat erzählt, dass sie doch so, na wie, mal der, mal der, also man pickt sich, man guckt, hört und wenn man denn findet, wird im Nachhinein gesagt, ah ja, da war ja was im Rahmen der Ermittlungen. So soll das denn, aber ob es denn nun wieder stimmt.
Gut, aber danke, dass du angerufen hast, weil das wollten wir mal wissen, ob wenigstens einer so ein Zettel bekommen hat. Danke Kai.
Ja doch, also es gibt 100 Prozent ja.
So, Peter noch aus Schauernheim. Hallo Peter.
Hallo, hallo, guten Abend.
Du bist Netzwerkadministrator.
Richtig, genau. Von öffentlicher Verwaltung, sprich bei der Gemeinde. Und ich wollte zwar fragen, wie da die restliche Sache ist, weil der Staat fängt jetzt an mit Signaturkarten für die Bürger, dass man eindeutig identifizieren kann, ob dieses Formular, diese Mail von Bürger kommt. Aber wie ist das jetzt mit den Usern bei mir? Die haben ja teilweise E-Mail-Accounts von der Gemeinde auch daheim. Und zu was bin ich da verpflichtet? Wie läuft da die Situation ab?
Also wenn es Mitarbeiter der Gemeinde sind, ist es eine geschlossene Benutzergruppe. Das ist nicht Öffentlichkeit.
Ist es keine Öffentlichkeit?
Nee.
Weil sicher die Gemeinde ja die Öffentlichkeit ja darstellt, oder? Die Verwaltung in dem Sinne.
Die öffentliche Verwaltung, aber doch nicht die Öffentlichkeit.
Ja, gut klar, natürlich, ja, aber ist es dann gleichzusetzen mit einer Firma?
Eigentlich ja.
Ja, es ist eine geschlossene Benutzergruppe, lieber.
Also muss ich da jetzt in der Hinsicht mir keine Gedanken machen. Das wollte ich wissen. Weil ich hab ja vielleicht jetzt da nochmal irgendeine andere Rechtsprechung oder irgendein Zwischending.
Ich denke, wir sind ja alles keine Juristen, kann ich nur wiederholen, aber ich denke, aus unserer naiven Leihensicht müsste da jetzt nichts irgendwie befürchten oder so. Aber ich denke, wenn du bei einer öffentlichen Verwaltung arbeitest, dann sollte das doch irgendwie einfach sein, irgendwie mal innerhalb dieser Verwaltung irgendwie eine andere Verwaltung anzusprechen, die mit diesen Dingen näher zu tun hat. Nämlich die Regulierungsbehörde für Post und Telekommunikation.
Ja, zum Beispiel, die wissen, wie das ja ist. Mit Verwaltung und Verwaltung, da klappt das ja an der Kommunikation ja nicht immer, das sich gerne erwünscht.
Öffentlichkeit heißt doch, dass ich das jedermann anbiete. Ach so, ja gut. Das ist natürlich, das mach ich natürlich in dem Fall.
Ja und jetzt als Gegenbeispiel, es gibt ja zum Beispiel auch Gemeinden, die bieten zum Beispiel ihren Usern Web-Space bei den Gemeinden an, beziehungsweise auch eine E-Mail-Adresse. Zum Beispiel adddeinort.de. Was ist denn dann, wenn ich dann auch praktisch einen ISP, der E-Mails anbietet?
Klar, das ist hier Berlin.de, gibt's das ja auch. Kannst du dir ja auch E-Mails holen? Na klar, das ist, dann bietet die Gemeinde, aber es ist ja dann meistens wieder, also entweder, ich glaube, das ist selten echt die Behörde, ist das dann irgendeine Firma, die da aufsagt wird damit und die bietet z.B. Kommunikationsdienstleistungen für die Öffentlichkeit an und muss damit eben entsprechende Schnittstellen schaffen.
Ja gut, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel einen Exchange betreibe und sag, ok, oder bezahl ich jetzt mehrere E-Mails selber und sag, alles klar, User aus meinem Ort, ihr könnt euch ein Adress mal mir holen und dann fall ich doch aber in dem Punkt wieder drunter.
Ja, und wenn du dann mehr als 1000 User hast, jetzt nicht auf einem Server, sondern insgesamt in dieser Anlage, dann musst du auch die Schnittstelle schaffen.
Ich lese mal von der Webseite der Rektep vor. Die Verpflichtung zur Vorhaltung von Überwachungstechnik gilt grundsätzlich auch für Betreiber, die E-Mails Server der Öffentlichkeit zur Nutzung anbieten. Da steht in Klammern sogenannte Web-Poster. Jeder Kunde des Web-Posters, für den E-Mail Accounts auf dem Server eingerichtet sind, zählt als Teilnehmer. Solange nicht mehr als 1000 solcher Teilnehmer eingerichtet sind, ist der Web-Poster gemäß §3 Absatz 2 Nummer 5 TK-IV von der Vorhaltepflicht befreit. Das heißt also, wenn ich einen Server betreibe, wo Leute sich Mailboxen einrichten lassen können, dann bin ich Host Provider. Wenn es mehr als 1000 werden, bin ich auch verpflichtet, solche Anlagen vorzuhalten. Das findet sich auf der Webseite der Regulierungsbehörde unter technischer Umsetzung von Überwachungsmaßnahmen.
Wobei bei Peter jetzt natürlich die Frage ist, ob er, wenn er bei einer deutschen Behörde arbeitet, nicht ohnehin noch anderen Verpflichtungen unterliegt, die ohnehin wollen, dass er bestimmte Sachen einfach frei an andere Behörden weitergeben kann, die ermitteln. Aber es ist interessant zu sehen, dass du, Peter, obwohl du da jetzt bei so einer Behörde arbeitest, selber noch nicht genau Bescheid weißt, also es scheint noch nicht alles so klar vermittelt worden zu sein.
Das ist genau der Punkt, darum war da auch meine gewisse Ungewissheit da, wo ich jetzt sage, okay, zu was zähle ich, wenn ich behandle wie eine Firma, wenn ich behandle wie eine öffentliche Instanz oder wenn ich behandle wie eine andere. Das war halt meine Grundfrage.
Du kannst ja mal einen schönen internen Brief schreiben.
Und als Behörde auch immer nochmal den Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten fragen. Weil der ist da nämlich auch interessiert.
Ich glaube, den werde ich morgen gleich mal anfragen.
Danke dir, Peter.
Ich danke auch. Schönen Abend noch.
Jetzt helfen wir sogar schon den Behörden. Sind wir nicht lieb. Ja, der Rocco ist am Telefon aus Cottbus. Hallo, Rocco. Mensch, jetzt kommen die ganzen Sättelchen hier.
Ja, ich wollte meinen selber auch mal dazu. Also ich habe auch so einen Brief von der Staatsschutzbehörde gekriegt, dass mein Telefon irgendwie mal einen Monat lang abgehört wurde.
Hast du dein Radio zufällig noch an dem Hintergrund? Ja, jetzt ist es besser. Dann hat das Ganze nicht so einen Konzerthallen-Charakter.
Ja, ich wurde irgendwie von ein paar Nachbarn denunziert, dass ich ein Waffen- und Drogenhändler bin. Naja, und Endeffekt von der Geschichte war, dass eben das SEK mein Haus gestürmt hat.
Das klingt ja schon was filmreif.
Ich fand das nicht so gut.
Hast du auch deinen Hund erschossen?
Naja, die haben auch meinen Hund geschossen. Gott sei Dank nicht getroffen. Ich hab noch die Einschüsse der Treppe.
Ich stelle diese makavere Frage, da war doch dieser Einsatz in Leipzig, Dresden, in den neuen Bundesländern sozusagen, wo Polizistenkollegen seinen Hund erschossen haben bei einem SEK-Einsatzkommando, weil sie sich in der Tür geört haben. Gibt's schon immer wieder.
Und wie kommst du mit deinen Nachbarn jetzt so klar?
Ach naja, ich löchle sie immer an. Das macht die Klamotten auch ein bisschen erweiliger drüber. Also was soll ich machen? Ich kann nichts machen. Wenn ich auf die Straße gehe, dann wäre ich bloß weggehaftet. Also das bringt alles nichts.
Wir müssen natürlich pro Forma noch fragen. Du bist nicht zufällig Drogen- und Waffenhändler, oder?
Natürlich nicht. Ich war auch schon ein paar Sachen in meinem Leben gemacht, die nicht so legal waren, aber nie irgendwie über die Stränge geschlagen.
Ja, ich meine, sicherlich kannst du ja dann überlegen, ob du gegen diese falsche Denunziation auch noch irgendwas Rechtliches machen möchtest. Das geht ja nun auch. Also wenn jemand irgendwie falsche Behauptungen aufstellt, du würdest irgendwie Straftaten begehen, dann ist das ja auch schon wieder rechtlich ein Vergehen.
Das muss man sich überlegen. Da wird jemand wirklich in sein Grundrecht eingegriffen. Das heißt, da wird irgendwie die Wohnung gestürmt, da wird das Telefon überwacht aufgrund von irgendwelchen Hinweisen. Das ist natürlich eine Frage der Richtervorbereiter. Wir hatten ja auch am Anfang mal die Frage, wie kompetent oder wie kritisch sind eigentlich die Richter bei so einer Anordnung? Und es gibt halt einige Fälle, die da mich zweifeln lassen, wie kritisch die Richter wirklich sind. Gucken die sich das genau an? Wegen die ab? Ist es wirklich das letzte Mittel? Oder versucht vielleicht die Polizei auch nur, sich ein bisschen das Leben einfach zu machen? Weil so eine Abhörmaßnahme ist natürlich total bequem. Dann muss ich nicht losgehen, da brauch ich keine Spurensicherungsteams, da muss ich keine V-Leute einschleusern, drücke einfach an meinem PC auf irgendwie klick abhören oder irgendwie klick einmal die E-Mail hier auf dem Bildschirm und schon bin ich da. Das ist halt ein recht kostengünstiger, das ist eine recht einfache Variante. Und das spart mir möglicherweise Monate oder sogar Jahre lang Ermittlungsarbeit, klassische Ermittlungsarbeit. Und deswegen wird von der Polizei dieses Mittel natürlich auch nicht immer als das unbedingt allerletzte Mittel genutzt. Wie in deinem Fall ja auch, offensichtlich, oder möglicherweise. Weil wenn sie sauber ermittelt hätten, dann hätten sie festgestellt, dass da eben nichts ist.
Ja, wir waren einfach zu früh. Ich kam auch nie irgendwie ein Schriftstück darüber, oder irgendwas.
Entschuldigt haben sie sich auch nicht?
Ach, natürlich nicht.
Also ich hatte so ein Rauchgerät zu Hause gestehen.
Ich hatte so ein Rauchgerät zu Hause gestehen, das haben sie beschlagnahmt.
Und haben sich ganz toll gefühlt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich haben sie gedacht, die haben einen großen Fisch an der Hange. Ich wüsste es nicht.
Viel Spaß noch mit der Treppe, ne? So, 031 77 97 110, gleich gibt es hier die letzte halbe Stunde auf Fritz. Wir machen gleich erstmal Nachrichten. Ihr könnt aber natürlich noch weiter anrufen. Ja, Mails schreiben ist auch gut. 99atchaosradio.ccc.de Wir haben jetzt den Beweis, dass auch Leute informiert worden sind, wenn sie abgehört worden sind. Da können wir jetzt im Grunde Schluss machen und danken. Und ihr könnt natürlich noch weiter erzählen. Ach so, wir würden gleich, wenn ihr Interesse habt, mal auf den praktischen Part bei der ganzen Verschlüsselung eingehen wollen.
Das versprechen wir noch mal ganz hoch und heilig. Nach den Nachrichten erklären wir nochmal, wie das mit der Verschlüsselung funktioniert.
Wenn ihr da irgendwie Erfahrungen gesammelt habt und Tipps geben könnt, was ihr da benutzt und ob ihr E-Mails verschlüsselt, wie einfach oder schwierig das ist, dann könnt ihr ja auch gerne anrufen, dann müssen wir nämlich nicht alles erzählen. 031 77 97 110 ist in dem Fall die Nummer.
Wenn Fritz über Satellit, dann Astra Digital Radio, Transponder 30.
030. Wetter, klassisch, die Nacht, Schnee, Regen, es kann blatt werden, die Temperaturen sinken auf 2 bis minus 1 Grad. Also friri friri, Vorsicht, tagsüber fällt dann zunehmend Regen, bei Höchstwerten zwischen 6 und 8 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötter Heinrich.
Bundeskanzler Schröder hat am Abend in Berlin das Einstein Jahr eröffnet. Anlass sind sein 50. Todestag und die Entwicklung der Relativitätstheorie vor 100 Jahren. Schröder würdigte Albert Einstein als glänzender Naturwissenschaftler, der stärker wahrgenommen werden müsse. Die Einberufungspraxis zur Wehrpflicht steht im Einklang mit dem Grundgesetz, das hat das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig entschieden. Damit ist ein anderes Urteil hinfällig. Angesichts vieler Ausnahmen bei den Einberufungsbefehlen war ein Kölner Gericht von einer Verletzung des Gleichheitsprinzips ausgegangen. Es gab damals der Klage eines Studenten statt. Großbritanniens Premierminister Blair hat die Folterung irakischer Gefangener durch britische Soldaten verurteilt. Vor dem Parlament versicherte er, die Schuldigen würden zur Rechenschaft gezogen. Bekannt wurde der Skandal durch Fotos, die am Mittwoch an die Öffentlichkeit gelangt sind. In Indonesien gibt es wesentlich mehr Flutoffer, als bisher bekannt war. Das Gesundheitsministerium in Jakarta sprach heute von 166.000 Toten. Damit stieg die Gesamtzahl der Opfer durch die Flutwellen im indischen Ozean auf 220.000. Der Verkehr auf Ritz ist glatt auf den Straßen. Teilweise Fahrten müssen vorsichtig, keine aktuellen Meldungen, ansonsten gute Fahrt.
Am Samstag, dem 29. Januar, eröffnen wir den neuen ZWITZ Club im Postbahnhof am Ostbahnhof Berlin. Und weil das gefeiert werden muss, wird das gefeiert. Auf der Bühne 5x Live-Musik auf Deutsch. Der neue Fritz Club im Postbahnhof. Große Eröffnung. Wollt ihr mitfeiern? Mit allen Radio-Fritzen? Dann achtet auf ihn. Den Fritz-Card muss werden. Und reimt euch mit einem Fritz Club Reim in den Fritz Club Reim. Viel Glück und im Radio Reiste Musik.
Auf Fritz selbstverständlich. Die letzte halbe Stunde die knappe und wir haben euch versprochen, heute am dem Chaosradio, es geht um Lauschangriff, es geht um elektronische Kommunikation und deren Abhörung, dass wir auch noch mal über Gegenmaßnahmen reden, was man so kleinseitig machen kann, also was ihr zu Hause auf eurem Rechner so installieren könnt. Unter anderem gibt es natürlich die Möglichkeit der Verschlüsselung, die aber so einfach dann doch wieder nicht ist.
Also Verschlüsselung ist, selbst wenn ihr keine kriminellen Aktivitäten vor habt, selbst wenn ihr nicht befürchten müsst oder gut, das ist jetzt kein Argument, aber selbst wenn ihr nicht abgehört werdet, wenn ihr nicht überwacht werdet, ist es unter Umständen auch ganz sinnvoll, E-Mails zu verschlüsseln. Zum einen, also ihr macht es, ihr lernt damit umzugehen, ihr lernt, dass es Normalität ist, ihr packt ja wichtige Sachen auch in einen Briefumschlag rein und schickt sie nicht per Postkarte. Und insofern möchten wir das euch mal ganz dringend raten, einfach mal mit dieser Verschlüsselung zu probieren, wenn es erstmal funktioniert, das ist auch gar nicht so kompliziert. Wenn ihr erstmal diese Grundidee dahinter verstanden habt, kann man das machen. Es gibt ganz einfache Methoden, wie ihr wenigstens ein bisschen was tun könnt, damit ihr eigentlich nicht viel tun könnt, viel dazu tun. Das ist zum Beispiel, wenn ihr die Übertragung, wenn ihr zum Beispiel Webmail benutzt oder irgendwie bei Ebay unterwegs seid, einfach, dass ihr die Verbindung verschlüsselt. Das nennt sich dann HTTPS bei Webverbindung, also bei Webseiten, wenn ihr abruft oder irgendwelche Dienstnutze, wie zum Beispiel Online-Banking, da ist es eigentlich standardmäßig aktiviert. Da müsst ihr dann einfach nur darauf achten, dass da so ein Schloss-Symbol irgendwo im Browser angezeigt wird und dass dann HTTPS oben in der Verbindungszeile, in der Adresseile steht. Das ist also die allereinfachste Variante, die ihr nutzen könnt, um Verbindungen zum Internet, die ihr im Internet macht, zu verschlüsseln.
Richtig. Wobei jetzt natürlich in diesem Fall bietet die Bank ja, na gut, es ist eine geschlossene Benutzungsgruppe, weil es die Kunden der Bank sind, weil die Bank bietet ja eine Telekommunikationsdienstleistung, an die da ist Online-Banking.
Ist das eine Telekommunikationsdienstleistung? Was ist das, ein Teledienst? Teledienst, ja.
Na ja, gut, stimmt ja. Verzeihung. Na, wie dem auch sei.
Nennen wir GMX als Anbieter.
Verschlüsselung ist im Allgemeinen nicht jetzt nur im Bezug auf die TKÜV sinnvoll, sondern auch wenn man die staatliche legitimierte und richterlich abgesickte Überwachung jetzt mal irgendwie beiseite legen, bringt einem die Verschlüsselung der Kommunikation ja auch den Vorteil, dass niemand sonst das mitlesen kann.
Also keine neugierigen Administratoren, keine Internetprovider, keine Leute, die da irgendwie Langeweile haben, auch keine Leute, die mal irgendwie aus Spaß und Freude irgendwelche Sachen anzapfen und Sachen mitlesen.
Genau. Und bei der Verschlüsselung muss man jetzt eben, wie Frank schon angeführt hat, unterscheiden zwischen entweder nur verschlüsselte ich den Kommunikationskanal, also für die Dauer, wo ich irgendetwas über ein Netz übertrage, kann ich einen verschlüsselten Kanal aufbauen und kann darüber Informationen verschicken. Dann ist nur die Übertragung gesichert. Dann ist das im Klartext bei mir. Die Übertragung wird verschlüsselt und auf der anderen Seite kommt es auch wieder im Klartext an. Das ist also das, was man mit dem HTTPS macht oder auch als SSL generischer bezeichnet, das Secure Socket Slayer. TLS ist auch noch ein schönes Aktonym, was in die gleiche Richtung geht. Da geht es also rein, wenn die Verschlüsselung Übertragungsweg ist. Das bringt mir da schon mal ein Vorurteil. Dann kann ich aber auch noch ein anderes Verfahren machen und kann die Information selbst verschlüsseln. Dann muss ich den Weg nicht noch zusätzlich verschlüsseln oder kann auch beides tun. Wenn ich die Information selbst verschlüssel, da gibt es E-Mail-Verschlüsselungssoftware, die nennt sich PGP. Es gibt eine andere Software, die den gleichen Standard herrscht, die heißt GPG. Also selbst wenn man sich irgendwie vertippt, ist das immer noch irgendwie. Es funktioniert immer noch. Und da verschlüsselte ich eben die E-Mail unmittelbar nachdem ich den Text erzeuge. Die wird also dann schon bei mir auf dem Rechner in verschlüsselter Form abgelegt, wird danach über das unverschlüsselte Internet übertragen und landet auch in verschlüsselter Form auf der Festplatte des Empfängers oder auf dem E-Mail Server des Empfängers. Das bringt mir den Vorteil eben auch, dass selbst wenn da jetzt jemand irgendwie einen Trojaner auf meinem Rechner hat oder sonst irgendwas über eine Backdoor oder Spyware an meinen Rechner kommt, das ist immer noch verschlüsselt auf dem Rechner selber. Es ist nicht nur die Übertragung, sondern tatsächlich die Information als solches verschlüsselt.
Und vor allem, es muss auf dem Mailserver, über den die Mails laufen, wird die Mail nicht entschlüsselt. Das heißt also, die ist wirklich auf der gesamten Strecke einfach vollständig verschlüsselt. Und bei einem Verfahren wie dieses HTTPS Verfahren, da ist zwar die Verbindung zwischen mir und meinem E-Mail-Anbieter, also zum Beispiel Yahoo oder gmx oder web.de, ist die Verbindung zwar zu diesem Server verschlüsselt, aber dann wird sie auf der anderen Seite erst mal wieder entschlüsselt, der Inhalt oder die Kommunikation, die da stattfindet.
Ja, weil die die Verschlüsselung einer, also der Transport von E-Mails geht ja nicht direkt von User zu User, sondern da sind immer eine ganze Zahl von Servern dazwischen. Wenn ich jetzt eine E-Mail an Max schicke, dann liefere ich die bei meinem E-Mail-Server, also bei dem meines Providers beispielsweise ein, und der speichert die erst mal zwischen und liefert sie dann weiter aus an den E-Mail-Server hier vom LWB beispielsweise. Und dann hat Max dort einen Vorwart eingetragen, dass die E-Mail weitergereitet wird an eine andere Adresse und dann wird es nochmal an den anderen Server übertragen und so weiter. Also das sind eine ganze Reihe von Rechnern daran beteiligt, die alle eine Kopie sozusagen erst mal zwischen speichern, solange bis sie die E-Mail wieder abgeliefert haben bei der nächsten Station. Und wenn ich nur den Übertragungsweg von mir zu meinem Provider verschlüsselte, dann ist natürlich der dächtliche Übertragungsweg von meinem Provider zum LWB und von dort zum Maxs Provider dann wieder unverschlüsselt. Das bringt mir also da relativ wenig. PGP oder eben andere E-Mail-Verschlüsselungssoftware, es gibt da auch noch einen anderen Standard, der nennt sich S-MIME für Secure Multi-Path für das Internet. Oh Gott, was war es? Message Encoding oder so. Der auch eine Verschlüsselung der eigentlichen E-Mail, also der Information in dem Fall vornehm, und nicht nur des Übertragungsweges.
Ich denke, wenn ihr starten wollt, wenn ihr euch jetzt mal angucken wollt, ist vermutlich GNU-PG, also GPG kurz, die einfachste und kostengünstigste Variante. Also ihr könnt komplett ohne irgendwas zu bezahlen und um irgendwelche Software zu kaufen damit starten. Das gibt es als Plug-In, denke ich, für Outlook und auf jeden Fall aber auch für Thunderbird, also für ein freies Mail-Programm. Und ich meine auch mittlerweile für Eudora oder was sonst noch. Also nicht allzu exotische Programme.
Man muss nur dazu sagen, ihr nehmt das natürlich alles immer so selbstverständlich, wenn ihr es auch benutzt und eure Freunde es benutzen, aber das Problem ist, eure Freunde müssen es halt benutzen, weil die müssen sich das Ding ja dann hinterher wieder entschlüsseln. Das heißt, es ist nicht so, als seid ihr secure und schickt eure Mails alle so raus. Der eine oder andere Kumpel wird dann sagen, ich hab jetzt nicht gelesen, weil mir einfach zu umständlich muss ich erst mal auspacken.
Richtig. Aber mittlerweile ist es so, ich kann zumindest sagen, dass von Thunderbird, was ich persönlich benutze, da ist es als ein Plugin dafür, wo ich jetzt einfach sagen, ok, installieren wir das und dann bräuchte ich das GnuPG. Das ist vielleicht noch ein bisschen komplizierter zu installieren, gibt aber auch eine gute Anleitung zu, wie das geht. Also ich würde mal sagen, mit einer Viertelstunde, wenn ich es noch nie gemacht habe, vielleicht mit einer halben Stunde Arbeit, kann ich das schaffen. Wäre gut, wenn mir jemand dabei hilft, der ein bisschen mehr Ahnung vielleicht von Computer hat. Aber grundsätzlich ist das alles machbar. Und wenn es erstmal integriert ist in mein Mailprogramm, dann geht da automatisch ein Fenster auf mit dem Hinweis, diese Nachricht ist verschlüsselt, geben sie hier ihr Kennwort ein und dann erscheint die Nachricht im Klartext. Und beim Verschlüsseln ist es genauso.
Also die Software noch mal als Hintergrund GPG oder auch GNU-PG genannt, ausgesprochen heißt das dann der GNU Privacy Guard, also unser Wächter der Privatsphäre, den man da einsetzen möchte. Jetzt wissen wir gut, man braucht so eine Software und die Leute, mit denen ich kommunizieren möchte, verschlüsselt, die brauchen die Software logischerweise auch, aber es reicht ja nicht nur die Software, sonst könnte ja jeder, der die Software hat, das auch wieder entschlüsseln, sondern ich brauche auch Schlüssel dazu. Darum geht es ja bei der Verschlüsselung. Und wenn man jetzt sich so naiv vorstellt, wie so eine Verschlüsselung funktioniert, dann denkt man ja erstmal auch aufgrund des Begriffes an Schlüssel und Türen und so weiter, wo das ja üblicherweise so aussieht, dass ich ein Schloss habe und da gibt es irgendwie fünf Leute, die haben einen Schlüssel zu dem Schloss und jeder, der einen Schlüssel hat, der kann halt diese Tür aufsperren. Solche Verfahren, die würde man jetzt im Kryptographie, also im elektronischen Verschlüsselungsbereich, als symmetrische Verschlüsselungsverfahren bezeichnen, weil zum absenden und empfangen der Nachricht jeweils der gleiche Schlüssel verwendet wird. Also, ja, das gibt nur einen Schlüssel, mit dem wird verschlüsselt und mit dem wird entschlüsselt. Solche Verfahren verwendet man für E-Mail-Kommunikation eigentlich nicht, sondern man nimmt sogenannte asymmetrischen oder auch Public Key-Verfahren. Und da werden im Prinzip zwei Schlüssel erzeugt. Wenn ich jetzt also anfangen möchte, für Schlüssel zu kommunizieren, dann benutze ich dieses GNU Privacy Guard und sage, erzeug mir einen neuen Schlüssel. Dann gebe ich dann an meine E-Mail-Adresse, zu der dieser Schlüssel gehören soll und noch ein paar andere Dinge. Und dann werden im Prinzip zwei Schlüssel oder zwei Teile eines Schlüssels erzeugt. Eines ist der sogenannte öffentliche Schlüssel. Das andere ist der private Schlüssel. Der Name impliziert schon. Der öffentliche Schlüssel ist etwas, was öffentlich ist. Den kann ich also veröffentlichen. Den gebe ich allen meinen Freunden. Den kann ich auch auf meiner Homepage zum Download anbieten, was auch immer. Weil mit diesem Schlüssel kann ich nämlich nur verschlüsseln. Die Entschlüsselung kann ich nur mit meinem privaten Schlüssel machen. Das heißt, den privaten Schlüssel muss ich hüten als mein sicherstes Geheimnis. Den darf ich niemandem geben, den darf ich nirgendwo veröffentlichen. Aber eben diesen öffentlichen Schlüssel gebe ich raus. Und dann können mir die Leute alle E-Mails verschlüsseln. Und nur ich kann sie entschlüsseln, weil ich den privaten Schlüssel dazu habe.
Das heißt, ich muss von meinen ganzen Freunden natürlich erwarten, dass sie auch das Programm installieren und auch alle so einen Schlüssel generieren, damit ich von ihnen sozusagen den Schlüssel bekomme, damit ich ihnen überhaupt E-Mails schicken kann.
Richtig. Das heißt also, wenn ich dem Max hier eine Mail schicken will, verschlüsselt, dann funktioniert das so, dass ich mir dieses Schlüsselpärchen erzeuge, private und öffentliche Schlüssel. Und den öffentlichen Schlüssel, den nehme ich und kann den Max per E-Mail schicken, weil der ist öffentlich, das ist kein Geheimnis. Und der einzige Trick dabei ist, oder was Max beachten muss dabei, ist, dass er sicherstellt, dass ich auch wirklich derjenige war, der ihm den Schlüssel geschickt hat. Da gibt es eine Methode zu, da kann man sich, da gibt es so alte Kennungen, die kann man sich vorlesen oder so zeigen, kann man vergleichen, am Telefon zum Beispiel, oder wenn wir uns das nächste Mal auf ein Bier treffen, ob das wirklich auch der Schlüssel ist. Und ich kann mir aber auch von anderen noch bestätigen lassen, das ist dann schon die erweiterte Methode mit Signaturen und so was. Und dann funktioniert das so, dass der Max diesen Schlüssel nimmt, den ich ihm geschickt habe und schreibt seine Mail und verschlüsselt die mit meinem Schlüssel, den ich ihm geschickt hab und schickt mir dann entsprechend die encrypted, die verschlüsselte Mail zu mir, die ich dann wieder mit meinem Teil des Schlüssels aufmachen kann.
Nun ist es aber nicht so, dass allein deswegen, weil hier wahrscheinlich Bundesamt für Sicherheit, Informationstechnik oder irgendwie sowas, das empfiehlt, dass man verschlüsselt. Die meisten Behörden würden eine verschlüsselte Mail wahrscheinlich nie akzeptieren. Die wüssten wahrscheinlich nicht mal, was sie damit anfangen sollen, oder? Also das ist das, was mich als Normalbürger doch interessiert. Ich möchte gerne meine Daten, die ich an irgendeine Behörde sende, verschlüsselt haben.
Es gibt wohl gerüchteweise auch einen großen öffentlichen Rundfunkveranstalter, dessen Mail-Server keine verschlüsselten Mails annimmt, weil dann die Spamfilter nicht mehr funktionieren. Oder die Virenfilter vor allem nicht mehr. Weil eben auch so ein Virus-Checkprogramm kann dann so eine verschlüsselte Mail einfach nicht mehr aufmachen. Das ist einfach verschlüsselt.
Nichtsdestotrotz gibt es also schon immer wieder Leute und auch Firmen, die dieses GPG oder PGP-Verschlüsselung verwenden. Und jetzt auch im nicht-technischen Bereich. Ich habe zum Beispiel leider relativ häufig mit einem Anwalt zu tun, der in meinem Auftrag arbeitet. Und ich kommuniziere mit ihm auch nur über PGP-Verschlüsselung oder E-Mail. Das ist ein Anwalt, kein Computerfreak, und der kann das auch bedienen. Also es gibt wirklich keine Ausrede dafür, dass man irgendwie das sagt, man kann das nicht benutzen.
Gut, aber es gibt natürlich Interessengruppen. Also so ein Anwalt, der auch weiß, er möchte gerne, dass die Sachen diskret ablaufen, das ist ja im Sinne des Anwaltsberufes natürlich auch etwas höher gelegt, die Latte als bei dem Normalverbraucher. Also da kann ich es auch verstehen. Aber es ist halt schwierig, es ist wirklich eine Hürde. Und bis man diese ganze Schlüsselnummer mal hat, dann verliert man den Schlüssel, diesen öffentlichen, dann hat derjenige wieder keine Homepage, dann muss man wieder anrufen, dann muss man wieder schicken mit einer normalen Melde, dann muss man wieder sicherstellen und so weiter. Das ist schon ein bisschen umständlich.
Es gibt Key Server für sowas. Also das Problem ist auch schon gelöst. Du kannst deinen privaten Schlüssel auf spezielle Server hochladen. Den öffentlichen. Den öffentlichen Schlüssel hochladen auf einen Key Server. Und ist dafür alle Leute wieder abrufbar über die E-Mail-Adresse. Wobei natürlich auch wieder ein bisschen das Problem ist, ist es wirklich von dir. Also irgendwelche Scherzgut, ich glaube auf unseren Key Server, sind glaube ich von Vorstand der CCC, drei öffentliche Schlüssel, die alle nicht uns gehören. Wo sich zumindest keiner dran erinnern kann, dass die mal erstellt worden sind. Und das ist halt ein bisschen das Problem dabei. Also es wäre schon sinnvoll, die quasi auch persönlich zu ergeben.
Also es ist sozusagen sicher, aber man weiß nicht sicher, an wem man es genau schickt, weil das natürlich keine Signaturbehörde ist.
Man schickt es schon an eine Person, aber man weiß halt nicht, wer das dann die Mail öffnen kann.
Du hast zwei Aspekte. Das eine ist eben die echte, tatsächliche Verschlüsselung. Das andere ist die Authentizität. Also dass du einfach weißt, ist derjenige, dem ich das jetzt geschickt habe, oder der Schlüssel, den ich verwendet habe, ist das tatsächlich der Schlüssel von Max? Oder ist das der Schlüssel von Frank, der nur einfach sagt, ja, ich bin der Schlüssel von Max? Also das ist einfach das Problem, dem man hier begegnet. Und das eine wird eben auch über Verschlüsselungen gelöst und das andere eben über sogenannte Signaturen. Und mit Signaturen kann ich jetzt unterschreiben. Also Max kann mir jetzt seinen Schlüssel geben und kann mir hohen Heilig versprechen, ja, das ist der Schlüssel, der mir gehört, den habe ich erzeugt. Das ist von niemand anders. Und wenn ich dem Max glaube, weil ich ihn kenne, dann kann ich einfach unterschreiben. Dann kann ich sozusagen diesen Schlüssel signieren und kann sagen, ja, ich kenne den Max und der Schlüssel, der gehört auch tatsächlich zu Max. Ja, und dann über diese Unterschriften, ja, dann gibt es jetzt vielleicht wieder den Jörg, der möchte Max eine E-Mail schicken, er hat jetzt aber keinen direkten Kontakt zu Max, aber er kennt mich und er sieht, ach, der Harald, der hat den Schlüssel von Max signiert, also glaube ich mal, dass das tatsächlich der Schlüssel von Max ist.
Also so ein Freunde-System quasi.
Das sind die sogenannten Trust-Metrics, wie das bezeichnet wird, die dann bei diesen Signaturen entstehen.
Zwei wichtige Einschränkungen zu PGP oder GNU-PG wären zu erwähnen, das eine ist, dass die Betreffzeile nicht mitverschlüsselt wird, das heißt, da muss man darauf achten, also hier irgendwie die aktuellen, oder Bomben, News, was auch immer, die Betreffzeile wird nicht mitverschlüsselt.
Man muss ein Large-Man sein oder irgendwas. Das hört überhaupt nicht auf, weil 90% der Spam irgendwie und sowas gibt.
Und was natürlich auch nicht verschlüsselt wird, ist die Tatsache, dass du mit jemand kommuniziert hast, auch verschlüsselt. Das heißt, wir haben vorhin schon gesagt, Polizei hat vor allem Interesse daran, also nicht in erster Linie an den Inhalten der Kommunikation, sondern an den Begleitumständen der Telekommunikation. Das heißt, wer kommuniziert in welchem Zusammenhang mit wem und wie ist dieses Netzwerk aufgebaut. Das sind interessante Sachen, die da abzulesen sind.
Ich glaube, einen groben Überblick haben wir gegeben, oder?
Ja, eine Sache vielleicht noch auch für dieses Problem, der Begleitumstände gibt es tatsächlich technische Möglichkeiten. Das ist dann nicht die Kryptographie, sondern die sogenannte Steganographie, wo man sich damit beschäftigt, wie ich in anderen Daten, die ich verschicke, geheime Informationen unterbringe. Ich schicke zum Beispiel dem Max ein Bild, einen JPEG oder so, und da drin ist dann speziell in dem Berauschen des Bildes, encoded, ist dann eine Information, die an ihn gerichtet ist. Und da kann ich dann natürlich auch schon wieder dieses Problem... Na gut, dann weiß ich immer noch, ich hab's an Max geschickt, aber ich weiß zumindest nicht mehr, dass überhaupt eigentlich eine Information jenseits des Bildes geschickt wurde. Und ich sehe auch nicht, dass Verschlüsselung stattfindet.
Also es gibt noch richtig ausgefuchste Methoden. Ihr könnt ja mal ein paar Freunde von euch Bilder schicken und dann gucken, ob ihr eine Antwort kriegt, wenn die rauskriegen, wie da drin was verschlüsselt worden ist mit irgendeinem Wasserzeichen. Abschließend noch kurz, nachdem wir das jetzt mal eben so geklärt haben, vielleicht habt ihr ja Geschmack dran gewonnen zu verschlüsseln. Eure Kommunikation der Henry. Ist er noch dran? Henry, bist du noch am Telefon?
Jo, super.
Das ist nämlich nochmal eine interessante Geschichte, die wir vielleicht zum Abschluss der Sendung preisgeben können. Du warst mal auf einem Seminar über den Bundesnachrichtendienst.
Ja, und da wurde eben gesagt, dass die Leute, also jeder Böse in Deutschland, sogar von den Leuten abgehört werden kann.
Das ist richtig. Das ist natürlich jetzt eine sehr grundsätzliche Aussage.
Klar.
Ja, da wurde uns so gesagt, weißt du, uns so vermittelt. Und ich find's ein bisschen dreif. Weil man hat ihm nicht seine Satzerfüße oder Beziehungsweise, weißt du?
Na ja, also ich denk der Nachrichtendienst ist ja auch nochmal eine separate Sache. Das ist ja ein Geheimdienst und keine Strafermittlungsbehörde. Wir haben jetzt hauptsächlich über polizeiliche Überwachungsmaßnahmen gesprochen. Der Nachrichtendienst macht ja, es gehört ja in eine andere Kategorie. Und natürlich kann jeder abgewacht werden. Es ist nur die Frage, wann, in welchen Fällen wird es genehmigt. Aber die technischen Möglichkeiten dafür, Telefonie oder auch mit Wanzen, irgendwie Wohnungen abzuhören und so weiter, die gibt's ja. Also können, ja, aber wann ist es erlaubt?
Henry, danke für den Anruf. Der Jörg hat schnell noch eine Frage. Die Sendung ist fast zu Ende.
Ja, kurze Frage. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen PGP und S-Mime?
Also S-Mime ist auch so ein Standard, glaube ich.
Ja, das ist halt ein technischer Unterschied. Man kann jetzt da, also das charakteristische Merkmal ist die damit verknüpfte Schlüsselverwaltung. Bei S-Mime werden sogenannte X509-Zertifikate verwendet, die eine hierarchische Public Key Infrastruktur voraussetzen, wohingegen bei PGP es die Trust Matrix gibt, was eher so, jeder kann jeden signieren und das gibt so ein Vertrauensnetzwerk. Bei S-Mime, durch die X509-Zertifikate, muss es eine zentrale Instanz geben. Also das kannst du eher in einer Firma machen, wo du sagst, gut, da gibt es die Abteilung Schlüsselausgabe und die weißt danach, dass jeder Schlüssel zum Mitarbeiter gehört. Wenn hier auch die Strukturen funktionieren, ist das gut.
Und wir verabschieden uns damit auch. Das war es schon mit dem Chaosradio. Schon ist gut, drei Stunden. Geredet über den großen Lauschangriff. Wenn ihr noch Diskussionsbedarf habt, was bei so einem Thema, was so langsam ins Gehirn sinkt, durchaus der Fall sein kann, es gibt noch Möglichkeiten.
Jo, schreibt an 99 at chaosradio.ccc.de, wenn ihr noch Sachen zur Sendung habt. Das heißt also Fragen, Input, irgendwelche Hinweise, Links, die ihr habt, gute Seiten. Schreibt an chaosradio at ccc.de, wenn ihr irgendwelche allgemeinen Sachen habt. Das heißt irgendwelche Themen, Wünsche, irgendwas zur Sendung, Wünsche, Grüße, wie auch immer. Es gibt eine Seite auf Wikipedia, auf dem deutschen Wikipedia. Das ist auch verlinkt von unserer Seite, homepage chaosradio.http.ch, chaosradio.ccc.de. Und ansonsten könnt ihr bei Wikipedia einfach nach dem Begriff Chaosradio suchen und klickt euch da zur Sendung 99. Da sind auch mal irgendwie alle Links, ein paar Fragen, die aufgekommen sind und wichtiges zur Sendung und vor allem auch ein Link zu BluePG drauf.
Hier geht's jetzt gleich weiter mit dem Night Flight. Auf Fritz verabschieden sich der Harald, der Frank und der Jörg, unser Gast. Mein Name ist Malotky, hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht und wir hoffen, wir haben mal wieder Anregendes geleistet. Und es bleibt ein bisschen im Kopf hängen. Das ist ja eigentlich immer so. Und deswegen verlassen wir uns auch drauf. Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal. Nächstes Mal übrigens hundertste Ausgabe des Chaosradio. Da wird schon gehüstelt, vielleicht wird doch was Besonderes geschehen.
Vielleicht aber auch nicht.
Der Harald ist schon so ein Logikfuchs.